this is jaco podcast number 119 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willick
good evening echo good evening on
September 11th 400 miles from the
collapsed World Trade Center towers
three dozen passengers and crew aboard
United flight 93 he remained in airborne
purgatory starting at 9:30 a.m. for some
30 minutes fourteen of them managed to
telephone either loved ones or operators
on the ground public relations man mark
Bingham got through to his aunts home in
California this is Mark he began I want
to let you guys know that I love you in
case I don't see you again then I'm on
United Airlines flight 93 it's being
hijacked two other callers from the
plane not only provided information but
also gleaned vital news from those they
phoned Tom Burnett chief operating
officer for a medical devices firm made
a number of brief calls to his wife
Deena speaking quietly he asked her to
contact the authorities and told her
that a male passenger had been stabbed
later that he had died a woman perhaps a
flight attendant was being held at
knifepoint and the hijackers claimed
they had a bomb Jeremy Glick a salesman
for an Internet services company also
managed to phone in a long conversation
with his wife Liz Glick said the
hijackers had put on these red headbands
they said they had a bomb they looked
Iranian the bomb was in a red box he
said the couple's told each other how
much they loved each other
Glick said I don't want to die and his
wife are
him that he would not she urged him to
keep a picture of her and their 11 week
old daughter in his head to think good
thoughts
Burnett's wife who had been watching the
news on television told him that two
planes had crashed into the World Trade
Center my god he responded it's a
suicide mission
by the time he phoned a third time after
news of the crash into the Pentagon she
told him about that too Burnett seems to
have been seated beside Glick and
apparently related all this information
to him were they to do nothing the two
men must have agreed they were sure to
die anyway when the hijackers crashed
the plane they resolved to fight for
their lives a group of us Burnett told
his wife are getting ready to do
something I'm gonna take a vote click
set on his call there's three other guys
as big as me and we're thinking of
attacking the guy with the bomb so began
the minutes of brave resistance the
clearly-defined act of courage that has
lived on in the national memory Glick
and others were equipped in more ways
than one
to confront the hijackers Glick was 6
foot 1 and a former college judo
champion Burnett at six foot two had
played quarterback for his high school
football team Mark Bingham was a huge
man six foot four and at 31 still
playing rugby a few years earlier he had
fended off a mugger who had a gun his
mother got the impression as he talked
from flight 93 that her son was talking
confidently with a fellow passenger she
felt that maybe someone had organized a
plan at 9:42 a GTE Verizon supervisor
based near Chicago began handling a call
from yet another
powerfully-built flight 93 passenger
Todd Beamer a star Oracle software
salesman was married with two sons and
his wife was expecting again he first
dialed his home number
but either failed to get through or
thought better of it instead explaining
that he did not want to upset his
pregnant wife
he asked the phone supervisor Lee Lisa
Jefferson to pass along a loving message
as they talked Beamer suddenly exclaimed
[__] oh my god we're going down Jesus
help us from the passengers around
Beamer came prolong shrieks of Terror
then he said no wait we're coming back
up I think we're okay now
shaken Beamer asked Jefferson to say the
Lord's Prayer with him our Father who
art in heaven
just before Beamer and the operator had
begun talking Cleveland lost Cleveland
control lost flight 93's transponder the
signal that indicates an airplanes
location and altitude that 9:55 the
hijacker pilot set a navigational aid
relating to the plane's direction he was
heading it indicated for Washington DC
Jeremy Glick still on the phone to his
wife Lyz said I know I could take this
guy with the bomb then joking he had
mentioned that the hijackers had knives
I still have my butter knife from
breakfast Todd Beamer continuing his
conversation with the GTE supervisor
Jefferson told her that he and a few
others were getting together to jump the
guy with the bomb was he sure that that
was what he wanted to do
yes came the response I'm going to have
to go out on faith I don't have much of
a choice
the plane was flying erratically again
operator Jefferson heard the sounds of
an awful commotion raised voices more
screams then are you guys ready and todd
beamers voice saying let's roll a phrase
that in family life he'd like to use to
get his children moving okay Jeremy
Glick called told his wife Liz I'm gonna
do it his wife told him he was strong
and brave and that she loved him okay he
said again I'm gonna put the phone down
I'm gonna leave it here and I'm gonna
come right back to it
Liz handed the phone to her father ran
to the bathroom and gagged flight
attendant Sandra Bradshaw was in the
galley boiling water for the passengers
to throw on the hijackers on the phone
to her husband she signed off quickly
everyone's running up to first class
I've got to go bye the cockpit voice
recorder registered the moment the
hijackers realized what was happening at
just before 958 a hijacker asks is there
something a fight there's a knock on the
door followed by the sounds of fighting
then in Arabic let's go guys Allah is
the greatest Allah is greatest Oh guys
Allah is greatest oh Allah oh Allah oh
the most gracious then loudly stay back
a male voice a native english-speaking
voice that Tom Burnett's wife has
recognized as that of her husband is
heard saying in the cockpit in the
cockpit followed by voice exclaiming in
Arabic they want to get in here hold
hold from the inside halt then from
several English speakers in uniform
unison hold the door and then from a
single English speaker stop him falled
repeatedly by sit down sit down
then again from an English
let's get them flight 93 now down to
5,000 feet had begun rolling left and
right Jeremy Glick father-in-law
listening intently on the phone his
daughter had handed to him now heard
screams in the background on the cockpit
voice recorder there is the sound of
combat continuing then in Arabic there
is nothing shall we finish it off no not
yet when they all come we finish it off
then from Tom Burnett I am injured the
flight data recorder indicates that the
plane pitched up and down climbed to
10,000 feet turned glicks father-in-law
phone clap to his ear heard more shrieks
muffled now like those of people riding
on a rollercoaster in Arabic on the
voice recorder oh allah oh allah o
gracious in english in the cockpit if we
don't we'll die in arabic up down up
down up down from a distance perhaps
from Todd Beamer roll it crashing sounds
then in Arabic Allah is the greatest
Allah is the greatest is that it I mean
shall we put it down yes put it in and
pull it down cut off the oxygen cut off
the oxygen cut off the oxygen up down up
down up down more violent noises for as
long as a minute and then apparently
from a native English speaker shut them
off go go move move turn it up
then an Arabic down down pull it down
pull it down down apparently from an
English speaker down push push push push
push
in Arabic hey hey give it to me give it
to me give it to me give it to me give
it to me
give it to me intermittent loud air
noise on the cockpit recorder moments
later in Arabic Allah is the greatest
Allah is the greatest Allah is the
greatest Allah is the greatest Allah is
the greatest there sounds of further
struggle and a loud shout from a native
English speaker no two seconds later in
Arabic in a whisper now Allah is the
greatest Allah is the greatest Allah is
the greatest Allah is the greatest
Jeremy Glick father-in-law still
listening on the ground heard
high-pitched screams coming over the
line Glick had left open when he left
the join to join the rush to the cockpit
then wind sounds followed by banging
noises as though the phone aboard the
plane was repeatedly being banged on a
hard surface after that silence on the
phone silence on the cockpit voice
recorder
and that is an excerpt from a book
called the eleventh day which came out
in 2011 by Anthony summers and Robin
Swan and we all know what that silence
meant flight 93 crashed into a field
near the diamond T mine in Stoney Creek
Township Somerset County Pennsylvania
killing 33 innocent passengers seven
innocent crew members and four demonic
hijackers
that day changed my world then it
changed our world the world as we knew
it and it commenced years and years and
years of war that has cost so many lives
and at some point on this podcast I'm
sure we'll go into more details about
the horrors of September 11th new
probably multiple podcasts but for today
I wanted to focus on one aspect of one
part of the life of one man on that
flight
the man named Jeremy Glick who by all
accounts was an amazing human being
son and a husband and a father but for
those of us who fight or who train
martial arts in general general
something caught our ears when he heard
about the heroics on flight 93
we heard that Jeremy Glick was a martial
artist that he was a wrestler and then
he was a judoka and as a wrestler he
wasn't competitive all-state wrestler
for Saddle River Dei school in northern
New Jersey and if you know anything
about New Jersey wrestling it's an
extremely competitive wrestling State
and beyond that as a judo player Glick
was an American national collegiate judo
champion while he was a student at the
University of Rochester and in September
of 2008 seven years after the incident
September 11th there was a memorial
ceremony at the crash site in
Pennsylvania and the United States Judo
Association placed a granite stone there
as a memorial with an inscription on it
and the inscription reads the United
States Judo Association promote promoted
Jeremy Glick to the highest rank of
black belt for living the principle of
Judo mutual welfare and benefit
sacrificing his life for our country
September 11th 2001 living the principle
of Judo and that's a bold statement it
indicates something very powerful and
very meaningful and as a patriot and as
a martial artist and specifically as a
jiu-jitsu practitioner which is where
judo was derived from I wanted to
explore a little deeper into the
principles of Judo to see what we can
learn from it
and I don't want to go into the full
details of explaining the relationships
between jiu-jitsu and judo but it is a
very close relationship it was one of J
Goro Pinos top students and Kay knows
the creator of judo but my eda that
brought jiu-jitsu to Brazil from Japan
and Inter
Douce jujitsu to Carlos and a Leo Gracie
and that's the beginning of Brazilian
jiu-jitsu as we know it today and my
eating even called it jiu-jitsu he
didn't call it judo and from what I
understand at that time even Kano had
not been actually calling it judo in
Japan he hadn't renamed it yet he was
still calling it jiu-jitsu and some
people were calling it
Kano jiu-jitsu or Kodokan jujitsu but
jiu-jitsu especially Brazilian jiu-jitsu
is without question rooted in judo and
if you trace it back just a little bit
further judo is also rooted back into
jiu-jitsu that's where judo came from
judo came from jiu-jitsu in mixed in
with all that there's all kinds of
evolution and there's changes and
there's politics and there's history but
there's that thread that ties them all
together and that thread can be
recognized in many of the principles
that are shared both in judo and in
jiu-jitsu the same principles that
played a role in Jeremy glicks attitude
on that clear sunny September day and
perhaps we can all learn something from
those principles and to look at those
principles I thought it would be best to
go to the source and I have a book
called mind over muscle that is it's
it's a compilation of writings from
jigoro kano and Cato was a very
interesting person he was a he was an
educator he was a pioneer in sports he
worked with the Olympic Committee he was
a jiu-jitsu practitioner eventually
founded judo and he founded the most
famous judo school the original judo
school the Kodokan and the book like I
said as you can tell by the title it's a
compilation of different sources of his
writings and there's a little bit of
overlap and repeat and I'll do a little
bit of that but what I like about it is
it gives a good overall view of the
ideas and the vision that Kano had for
judo so I know there's a lot of Judo
practitioners out there and obviously a
lot of jiu-jitsu practitioners out there
that listen to the podcast and everyone
knows that these two are closely related
and sometimes there's I guess you'd say
tension between the two sometimes but
the fact of the matter is they're so
closely related that it's it'd be more
it'd be more intelligent instead of look
for the tension between the two to find
where the two can complement each other
so here we're going to the book and once
again the book is mind over muscle
writings from the founder of Judo jigoro
kano
and here we go to start it off the
purpose of jujitsu see you interesting
that he starts this off it's talking
about jujitsu they're not even talking
about judo yet the original purpose of
jujitsu was to practice a method of
combat while combat may have been at the
core of jujitsu practice it also had the
related goals of physical education and
mental training there is little dispute
that because training to fight involves
moving the body in various ways
jiu-jitsu indirectly became a form of
physical education but for the same
reason it also became a method for
training the mind all forms of combat
required ingenuity and the use of
various tricks and devices so all forms
of combat all forms of combat this is
important because when if you're if
you're a a soldier you're a marine or
your own airman right now we're talking
about everything that you do and I'll
tell you what if you're a business
person we're talking about what you're
doing to all forms of combat require
ingenuity and the use of various tricks
and devices
so in the course of jujitsu training the
mind is unconsciously trained in many
ways courage composure composure and
other traits that are beneficial in life
can also be developed now I'll tell you
what this is important because people
ask me a lot like you know how did you
figure all this stuff out Jocko but
people ask me that mmm and you know I
always try and explain you know like it
was a long course and I was in the
military for a long time and I had an
open mind and I listened to paid
attention to the people that were
leading me and I paid attention the good
ones and I paid attention to the bad
ones but I'll tell you if I didn't I
jiu-jitsu opened my mind up and did
these things and again unconsciously
like I started to perceive things the
way that I was learning jiu-jitsu and
that's why I've got some I got you know
I've got friends and I've gotten in
jiu-jitsu over the years and you can
tell and I don't know what makes some
people get the bug and some people don't
get the bug but if you get the bug and
you start to think in a jujitsu mindset
then you'll it'll really open up your
mind now that being said there's some
people that are heavily into jiu-jitsu
but they don't apply jiu-jitsu to the
the other aspects of the life which is a
big mistake it's a big mistake
you got to apply it both ways and I
think that's one of the things that that
Kano was trying to do with judo was to
ensure that you did that to ensure that
his students did that hmm all right back
to the book it was my belief that with a
few improvements jiu-jitsu could become
a comprehensive method of physical
education intellectual training and
moral education I therefore spent
several years developing my ideas and
finally established the Kodokan judo I
did this by thoroughly researching the
jujitsu that it existed up until the
time up until that time as much as
possible keeping what I felt should be
kept discarding what I felt should be
discarded thoroughly studying the
techniques and theories and establishing
them in a way that would be most
applicable to today's society it's not
even talking about just combat he's
talking about like he not talk about
fighting he's like talking about
applying these things to society
so there's a little bit of yeah I think
he was young when he did this too he
established the Kodokan at a very young
age I want to say he was like 22 years
old he was really young so he studied
you did too thought some things were
good about it thought some things were
bad about it and said I'm gonna make my
own deal mm-hmm now here we talk a
little bit here there were there were
various reasons why I chose not to use
the term jiu-jitsu which described what
was ordinarily practiced and instead
employ the name judo the main reason was
that dough the dough part of Judo it
meanswe is the major force there's a
major focus of what the Kodokan teaches
whereas Jitsu skill is incidental I also
wanted to make it clear that judo was a
means of embarking on the way so he saw
this as like a complete a complete life
system right not just fighting this is
the way judo is the way for him and
that's why he instead of calling it Jiu
Jitsu we called it you know not not take
techniques but like the way back to the
book when we talk about jujitsu today
people often think of a technique in
which one does only dangerous things
such as choking an opponent and bending
his joints or even in extreme cases
killing him essentially we think of
something that is harmful to the whole
book to the body while offering no
benefits true Jiu Jitsu does not espouse
this in particular the Kodokan judo I
devised never involves doing anything
dangerous I cannot stress enough that
what I advocate is far from a violent or
dangerous sport now sure I understand
the principle there but just so everyone
knows judo doesn't play around you know
if you've if you've gone with a
high-level judo player you are getting
thrown hard and aggressively on to your
head yeah it's it's a brutal sport it's
it's very aggressive yeah do you think
that that's how or that's what because
when it comes down to the essence it's
like and this is just me totally
guessing where judo as it is now
it's like okay the goal is basically to
put the guy in his back that's it put
him down on the ground not to hit him
not to knock him down put him on the
ground right this kind of seems okay
that's really violent that's kind of the
little friendly competition put them on
the ground now with any competitive
situation Oh guys you're gonna get after
it and it slowly just evolves into all
these crazy things
it doesn't evolve it escalates even just
the whole way so even can consider like
basketball for example the goal put that
ball in that basket that's it you go
from here come close laughs whatever
then you get this competitive drive
these people athletic abilities all this
stuff now it's turning into weird slam
dunks now bright you didn't have to slam
dunk that thing but it's still the same
thing put in the ball you know and the
thing that's in this weird aggressive I
guess yeah I guess yeah I guess a layup
compared to a tomahawk slam dog right
yeah and if you compare a let's say some
sort of a basic takedown compared to
like a full upon the slide yeah I could
see your I could see your comparison
seem say there's an escalation yeah and
then his mind he was like hey look at
this is just a takedown yeah you tell
that to a 21 year old judo competitor
that's got you in there takedown you
yeah exactly right just like you know a
basket a basket you know oh yeah he made
that basket no but he slammed on you and
you know embarrass you in front of it
you know like it goes into this whole
different realm but the essence is still
there though is the basket just to take
that yeah all right here we go back to
the book the organization of Kodokan
judo is basically the same today as it
was when I established it but at that
time when explaining judo I divided it
into three parts it's use as a fighting
method martial art as a training method
physical education and as a method of
mental training including the
development of the intellect and morals
and the application of the principles of
Judo to everyday life see this is again
this is what's interesting to me is and
he said it was subconscious like I
subconsciously especially in the
beginning with jiu-jitsu
and I'll tell you was beyond just me
applying jiu-jitsu to like my life and
to what I had learned about combat I
also took what I had learned about
combat and applied that into jiu-jitsu
right like III said oh yeah you know
this is like when you flank someone
right yeah but even even when I first
learned one of the one of the biggest
wake-up calls that you get early in
jujitsu is like oh what I need to do is
attack your neck and when you defend
your neck I take your arm right that's a
flank right that's just a straight up
flank that's that's a game-changer like
that's a complete game changer when you
realize that that's a complete game
changer
well there's a seal buddy mine that had
been training when I first started out
he'd been training for like a year
no but he'd been training off and on
kind of bits and pieces and so then I
started training hardcore like everyday
yeah so after like two weeks like
literally two weeks I went trained with
him and I and I got him like a bunch of
times and I was all pumped up and and I
said to him I said hey you know what you
the mistake that you're making is you're
trying you're going for my arm and I
know you're going for an arm and I'd
know how to defend that I think you got
to go for something else
and then like a week later we rolled
again and he got me did what I told him
to do to me yeah I was like oh dang oh
dang so that was a big wake-up call
that's a big no-no it's it's a
revelation when you realize oh you've
got to do you got a set that you gotta
fight the person yeah that's what you
have to do yeah big wake-up call so
crazy to see two people rolling and all
they're doing is flanking each other
oh you're flanking the flag yeah but
what's interesting is as I started
working with like leaders and teaching
my leadership how important the idea of
what flanking is from a leadership and a
human interaction perspective another
such did you gotta flank people you want
to attack that ego yeah all right back
to the book two methods of instruction
are used kata which is a form and
randori which is free practice it's what
we call in the jujitsu rolling and when
establishing the Kodokan I employed a
method that emphasized randori
and by which cada naturally came to be
understood during randori practice this
is rather so he focused on rolling a lot
when he established kota comp a test
this is very interesting randori rolling
trains rolling its rolling it's good to
remember that yeah use it this is rather
like teaching composition without using
a grammar book or teaching the basis of
grammar while teaching how to write an
essay so this is like hey man write this
down are you gonna make some Corrections
and like that's that's basically rolling
live right now when there are only a few
people undergoing the training this was
not a problem
but the number of beginners gradually
increased and it became impossible to
teach cada at the same time as randori
so a few years after I established
Kodokan judo I created 15 kata four
throws and ten kata for combat called
kimi no kata which meant forms of
self-defense so he realized he couldn't
teach the same way he couldn't teach the
masses so what you know that's that's a
big change right there's a big big
change for anyone that's not into
martial arts there's a big big
difference between rolling and learning
kata and matter fact we make fun of kata
right I'm not saying that's a good thing
yeah but we shouldn't say we completely
make fun of it but like I'll see Dean
and let's say he's I can tell he's tired
you know he's looking all worn out
mm-hm and I'll see you oh yeah hey
what's going on man you want to train
some kata today meaning hey are we just
gonna go through the motions not axe
drill you know no we're gonna train
right so that when I say make fun yeah
you don't make fun of it because because
what we call kata basically in jujitsu
we call it drilling yeah right you're
gonna drill this drill drill drill which
drilling is part of winning you got to
drill to win right Andre Galvao
drill just make killers drillers make
killer there it was all those things
that being said we all know if you do
nothing but drill you're not gonna be
able to pull these moves off going live
and this with the old traditional
martial arts that was all cotton and all
kata will get you nowhere that's when
the guys when you saw that the 90s when
the jutsu invasion happened you know the
guy would try his 12-point strike kata
method against a blue belt in jujitsu
the blue belt will do a sloppy duggle
double leg take him down the ground and
choke him out cuz they rolled live they
did randori so you have to have balance
but you got a trained live randori and
at the same time you've got a drill too
so be careful don't do too much I want
seems like the drilling helps you get a
hold of what you do with your body and
then the brandori the light the rolling
yeah
gives you a you know controller or
better skill in dealing with other
people off rider so and that's what
Jesus is both you know where you can
kind of and you're gonna get you're
gonna get reactions that are different
right right and this is the same thing
this is the same thing like when I was
training guys in the teams like you
could teach them the basics of how to
enter a room and then how to move down a
hallway but as soon as you put another
person they're going against them yeah
is like different things happen yeah
different things are gonna happen you
got to be ready for it so you have to go
a lot i-i've told I told you this story
before but when when I first started
playing basketball and my coach I had
the old school he had the old school
Hoosiers coach right yeah you know the
old school you seen the movie Hoosiers
no oh dad
so in Hoosiers the guy's old school
coach like hey know you're not even
allowed to shoot were defense defense
defense real internals drill drill drill
we never scrimmaged and the first time I
played in a real game it was the first
time I played a real game I went down
the court and like called the play and
expected to be able to execute the play
that had run the little pattern and the
the other point guard just picked me off
I was in 7th or 8th grade he just picked
off every pass I threw I was just
because I'd never done randori on the
basketball court never scrimmage never
played you know you got to balance those
two all right
next back to the book next I would like
to briefly discuss free practice
involving throwing and grappling
techniques which I will refer to by
their Japanese names so the two Japanese
names and he's going to use her Khatami
Wazza and Naga Ozzy
now now walls it means technique right
and you probably knew that a lot of us
we a lot of us in jiu-jitsu we talked
about or we we want we know about Judah
we talked about nawaz ax and any waa-waa
za Nawaz it means ground work that's
what it means mat work basically is what
I mean i think i think the end he
actually means like laying down or
sleeping or something like that so it
means you're down on the ground Khatami
Wazza is the Khatami walls it is like
the grappling part but you're not
necessarily you're not necessarily
laying down in all grappling positions
so that's why they call it Khatami Wazza
but but Nagi Wazza is the throws alright
so here we go back to the book when I
was training I practiced Khatami Wazza
quite a bit but after coming to
appreciate Naga Wazza I came to believe
that Naga waz he should be emphasized in
the technical training aspects of Judo
this does not mean I considered Khatami
Wazza to be useless of course but I
stress practicing Naga Wazza first
followed then by khatami Wallis's so he
focused on the throwing techniques this
is because doing Khatami Wazza first
hinders progress in Naga Wazza
while it makes sense that learning Naga
wasa first makes it easier to remember
Khatami Wazza as at a later stage when I
established Kodokan I encouraged the
practice of Naga Wazza
precisely for that reason as a result at
that time a great great number of
experts in Naga Wazza were fostered in
the early years the Kodokan as a result
of emphasizing Naga Wazza however
Khatami Wazza gradually became neglected
that's very interesting so anyone that
knows anything about judo and Jiu Jitsu
one of the biggest differences is in
jiu-jitsu we focused small town on
ground work too much well you could say
too much right because there's there's
there's jiu-jitsu people that don't know
how to take someone down and that's very
problematic so he's saying that hey he
focused on that and you can kind of hear
what he's saying so if you it's real
easy to ignore the stand-up when you
realize how effective the ground game is
and you also realize that if you if you
understand
how to take the person down then you're
gonna get in good positions and all that
so he just kind of leaned in that
direction and says that it ends up
getting a little bit neglected and also
if you don't know the rules of Judo
emphasize the takedowns because the
rules of Judo if I take you down if I
throw you with a Nippon which means
something some other body part other
than your feet touches the ground before
your feet do it during the throw
I win automatically instant win it's
like a submission and so because of that
they practice a lot to stand up yeah
whereas in jiu-jitsu you can get thrown
ten times and you can still catch person
in a triangle you win you on the ground
doesn't matter yeah and you can get
pinned in judo too if you get held down
for thirty seconds about thirty it's
thirty Seconds on on your back you get
pinned you lose yeah that doesn't happen
in jiu-jitsu you can have someone across
side on you for four or seven eight
minutes yeah just you haven't even moved
you know you didn't lose and you sneak
out of there and grab a little camera
and get the victory sir all right back
to look at the Kodokan we study and
practice techniques with the purpose of
using mental and physical energy most of
fit most effectively in order to achieve
one's gold no matter what the endeavor
which is the basic principle of Judo and
he's gonna talk about this a ton the
basic principle of Judo is like
efficiency so those in training do not
merely know but this is so important
those in training do not merely imitate
the actions of the master or practice
without understanding the reasons behind
what they are doing but rather consider
the methods and train in accordance with
detailed principles for that reason what
once took five or six years to achieve
can now be accomplished in three years
this is huge in jiu-jitsu and I saw this
transition take place when I started
learning jiu-jitsu we learned moves
now everyone teaches concepts I mean you
still teach moves but if you don't know
the principles of them and it's the same
thing when I was teaching guys in the
teams like you teach them a maneuver on
the battlefield if you can learn the
mechanics of the move on the battlefield
but if you don't understand why those
mechanics are important then it doesn't
make you don't even have you don't have
it don't get it
same thing in the business world you can
tell someone like hey here's what you
should tell your subordinates right now
yeah but that technique
can use it and it'll work okay but
that's nothing compared to saying here's
why it's important that you tell your
subordinates this thing and here's how
you want to lead them that's what gives
them the game is when they understand
the principles yeah yeah that's why
those introductory courses are so
critical
yeah and I'm talk about jujitsu FC where
you get a new guy first day guy and he
jumps in a class and the class they're
teaching the you know the mechanics of a
certain move meanwhile everyone in the
class they're not first day people they
know the concepts behind it but they
come in and it's just it's just a
different language it doesn't stick yeah
yes yeah it's like trying to teach
someone if you if you if you had a
non-native English speaker and you walk
in and you're gonna teach him of you
know a vocabulary word yeah which is
like you know audacious right he there's
no context to put that in that's not the
word to teach him he doesn't even know
how to say I yeah so when you start
teaching someone at home or Plata yeah
and they don't understand when I'm walk
are is they're gonna have issues yeah
that's like you know fundamentals do you
want ketchup with that teach someone who
doesn't know any English do you want
kids with teach them that and then send
them out he doesn't know when to use
that you know I know how to say it
well you're not just gonna roll into the
post-office and be like hey do you want
ketchup with that it doesn't make sense
no it's unusable back to the book
various records and accounts have been
passed down over the ages with regard to
the true meaning of jiu-jitsu then he's
talking about the actual word jiu-jitsu
but few of them are accurate it can be
said though that the name apparently
derived from the expression jus yoko go
oshizu which can be trained Lee
translated as softness controls hardness
this expression needs closer attention
let's assume I have an opponent who
possesses power vowed to the value of
ten whereas I must face this opponent
with power only to the value of seven
when my opponent thrusts at me with all
of his energy it follows that if I
resist I will be overcome even if I
expend all my power
if however rather than resist my more
powerful opponent I adjust and adapt to
his energy and pull back he will
fall forward under the strength of his
own attack his power of 10 will become
merely a power of three and he will
stumble and lose his balance I will not
be pulled off balance and can pull away
maintain my stance and retain my
original power of seven in short
resisting a more powerful opponent will
result in your defeat whilst adjusting
you to and evading your opponent's
attack will cause him to lose his
balance his power will be reduced and
you will defeat him this can apply
whenever the relative values of power
thus making it possible for weak
opponents to beat significantly stronger
ones there you go yes sir that's the way
it works
can it level 10 beat a level looking a
level one beat a level 10 that's tricky
there's that there's a there's a point
right yeah there's a point where like
yeah yeah because there's like even that
what he's talking about I like how he
did it in numbers like how he did that
but the reality is like that it's again
cool to have the numbers but it's not
they're not absolute numbers there's a
lot of gray area in there so the idea is
to take his tan and use almost like
using part of his tan for on top of your
seven because you're going the same way
but it's like how much of that 10 are
you gonna use if you're one you better
you'd be using nine you know master yeah
you gotta be using a lot of his number
you know but now this is one of those
things this is one of those things that
I subconsciously learned from jujitsu
and I applied it all the time especially
in dealing with relationships and I've
talked about it here a million times if
like hey don't attack the ego don't
attack the strong point right yeah
that's just complete just just to
complete jujitsu mentality that's what
it is and and it works if you attack
that strong point son zou hardiwar 2500
years old if you attack the different
heavily defended position you're not
gonna win if you go against a power of
10 and you've only got a power seven
you're not gonna win not gonna even if
you use full power
even if all power in fact it's gonna be
worse for you especially the other guy
knows he's gonna use that seven he's
gonna use that in addition to his 10
he's gonna beat you with a 17 to zero
yeah and
that actually backs up or kind of refers
back to your point where Kenna
when you say Kenna level one beat a
level ten so a level if they both know
jujitsu or judo then you know it's way
because he knows the same thing as you
but you know if you're nine if you're
better than the guy for an eye and then
you know your friend start to go up
this doesn't washer no doubt no doubt
about that but I think that's where
people they get jammed up where they're
like hey what do I thought size didn't
matter in jujitsu
oh yeah if everyone's doing jujitsu of
course size matters just like a decent
gonna matter just like how tall you it
matters how strong Lin matters when you
all know the Jiu Jitsu
yeah when you that's like a dude said
the other day Jiu Jitsu is not important
as important in the UFC as it was the
guy that just beat for doom big tall
badass guy from Russia Cal cough or
something sorry bro
he but he said hey it's not as important
anymore and the fact that but you're
right you know why it's not as important
because everybody knows is it so yeah
it's not as important to go you roll in
there without knowing any jujitsu you're
gonna get ya submit it you feel employee
yes yeah yeah exactly
all right back to the book there's a
popular parable that goes thus a jujitsu
which means a jiu-jitsu practitioner was
grabbed by a sumo wrestler at that point
that jujitsu said you're a sumo wrestler
yet you can't grab any tighter than that
angered the sumo wrestler attempted to
adjust his grip as he did so he loosened
it slightly at that moment that jujitsu
quickly lowered his body and escaped
from the sumo refs loose grip all right
now there's another we're gonna talk
about this theory called Sirocco
sajin that's you and I apologize to
everyone that speaks Japanese I'm sorry
Tim Ferriss I'm sorry I should have
waited for you to come and do this with
me so you could correct me but here here
we go
one's mental and physical energy must be
used most effectively in order to
achieve a certain goal that is to say
one must apply the most effective method
or technique for using the mind and body
if we use the term Ciriaco for one's
mental and physical energy
this should be expressed to Yoko Susan
Casio which means best use of one's
energy we can shorten this simply to
Ciriaco Zegna which means maximum
efficiency maximum efficiency this means
that no matter what the goal no matter
what the goal in order to achieve it you
must put your mental and physical energy
to work in the most effective manner
this is like common sense right but how
often are we wasting energy how often
are we wasting energy
we're wasting energy all the time back
to the book when I was a child I learned
the jiu-jitsu of the past however the
dad jiu-jitsu had no basic principle I
learned various methods from one teacher
he taught me how to place my hips and
pull to throw an opponent and how to
choke someone but he did not teach me
anything about what principles were
involved or how to apply those
principles but that's I think that's the
same that as jiu-jitsu hit America I
think everyone was learning like that
like here's how you choke someone but
you weren't learning the system as I
studied further I found that one one
teacher taught differed from a what
another taught there was no basis upon
which to decide which one was correct
that was the reason I began to make a
thorough study of jiu-jitsu
now what I would say about that is you
don't need to decide which one is
correct like when you learn an armbar
from one person you learn a lot armbar
from someone else you're gonna learn
good things from both of them neither
one of them is correct and one of them
might be correct in this situation or
with this body style and the other ones
corrected in different situations the
different body style I think if we look
to knose personality traits like he's a
guy that's real or girly and I think
that's yeah he's every a guy like Jordan
Peterson people would put him in the
high conscientious and high a high and
orderly that's a very orderly person and
so for him like there's a right answer
and there's a wrong answer
and I think you see that in judo and
that's why judo is much more disciplined
highly disciplined like go to a judo
competition there are no yelling it's
Gregorio jujitsu competition it's mayhem
yeah yeah right and they've tried to
tighten that up like they try and make
it less crazy but they haven't succeeded
Juju's crazy do competitions are crazy
judo competitions are not like that yeah
bro did you see there's a clip a-doodle
clip on online wherever I saw it but
it's a clip and so this guy wins right
the real dramatic win like maybe he
wasn't supposed to win her honor maybe
he's an upset maybe not or maybe it was
a finals I don't know but it was a real
dramatic win he wins and he's like you
know how they yell and they be all happy
whether he did that any kind of stood
over the guy oh just a second like I
split like pretty short DQ DQ yeah just
like that so legit like men in jiu-jitsu
MMA you see that all day yeah see that's
that's the that's one of the reasons I
wanted to talk about this is like that
is a quality thing you know it's - and I
guess this is different on the east
coast or west coast the East Coast like
one of my buddies Jill he came and
watched some wrestling with me with some
high school wrestling and they Pat
Africa with it they penalize people like
oh no you're not allowed to do that like
they're strict when you get done when
you get done wrestling you just got
pinned you get up you get to the senator
mat you put your hand out to shake hands
that's it yeah they'll complain to the
ref there's no this other crap no you do
what you're supposed to do and that's
awesome because that you know what that
teaches people teach people how to
control their emotions yeah yeah I
remember in Pop Warner you know my only
frame of reference was watching football
on TV NFL spike in the ball doing the
ickey shuffle back in my day Akina Mikey
woods anyway back did it um and so you
know we play Pop Warner football my
first year I knew that our coach was
super disciplined
like the kind where you had to everyone
had to wear high white socks white shirt
like a real discipline and I see how the
teams and they difficult issues all this
stuff
that's all I knew though so it was clear
you couldn't spike the ball you couldn't
do any dance or whatever you give the
ball to the ref that's that's it when
you make a touchdown so we played this
team that will remain nameless and they
go they did you don't want to bring up
the old rivalries
babymaker actually was a team from out
of town acts huh
and they he spiked the ball little kids
spiked the ball and does the thing or
whatever share flag it's it's a penalty
oh you actually even in colleges like
that oh right
I don't know yeah in college football's
like that you can do you can do more for
sure but yeah Pop Warner anything you do
anything you you throw the ball you put
your hands up for too long if you put
your hands up for too long after you
make it touchdown that's a penalty all
that sports been like condo that's legit
right I think so especially as little
kids I think so especially even as big
kids yeah when you're a professional um
this is what he said when you're a
professional football player you can and
you make a touchdown something about
like that's your job or whatever so yeah
you have the right to be happy about it
that's kind of but when I think about it
now it's like shoot if you're
professional you focus on your
profession do you think so
I guess it's whatever your philosophy is
and you could say like UFC I mean it's
really cool it's so much cooler when
someone wins and they just are like
check yeah it's like know what you're
yeah we're just go out there and just
destroy someone that just comes like
yeah thanks good match yeah that is true
I know we all want to see the high band
jump on top of the cage sells tickets in
blah blah blah but there's nothing
better than just a cold-blooded killer
that just comes out and and you're it's
interesting sometimes fighters do it I
think I was watching cowboy Cerrone or
the bait like knock some grounds walked
away like it was nothing
yeah yeah I do this every single night
yeah yeah like yeah yeah but but they
don't show that clip or like Mark Hunt
yeah yeah mark hunt just doesn't walk
away not now just knocks dude I just
walks away I guess yeah can I get my
piece of chicken now I'm hungry yeah but
the reason that those are so cool like
phaidor that's great example by the way
where he's just no he's not getting
hyped up no the fight he's not act up
afterwards you know no emotion is this
cold yeah that that gets that seems more
appealing because it's in contrast to
all the hype all the high more this guy
get hyped up and whatever so if everyone
was like that he would be like
it would still would be cool but even
then I'm probably just comparing it to
like how I know it can't knock a hybrid
Conor McGregor gets pumped I mean yeah
exactly right so you know it there's a
there's a dichotomy yeah there's a
dichotomy
I think the preferred method though is
cold-blooded yeah but when you and this
is really what it is and this goes for
the NFL to benefit for sure yeah um it's
it's a show you gotta remember yeah
that's a show exactly right so in that
means to for the NFL where we fit just
go sit around and watch old phaidor
fight so you know Sakuraba was kind of
like Sakuraba didn't celebrate yeah
horse yes uh Carrabba was pretty cool
too yeah I totally cold-blooded but just
so you say man like Connor and like
these guys who do put on a show that's
kind of cool too all right back to the
book in the end I learned from various
teachers in various schools but when one
method of instruction differed from
another I had difficulty determining how
to resolve those differences as I
studied further I came up with the
principles I've described in order to
achieve your goals you must put your
energy to use most effectively again
I'll just say that you don't have to
choose like this one's right and this
one's wrong you need to absorb both
those methodologies and have them both
in your toolkit cause you might need
them mmm you know say yeah I don't like
having the metric wrench sockets and the
you know oh yeah yeah and the other one
you got the other ones got a need that
one the other one you come across a bolt
that's metric yeah you better be ready
for that here's that here's some stuff
that's interesting calisthenics
are generally based on physiology and
Anatomy so they do not result in the
development of unbalanced body nor are
they harmful to the internal organs but
they are not without without drawbacks
because each individual movement has no
meaning and because calisthenics have no
secondary benefits they are
uninteresting calisthenics are widely
used in Japan and abroad but few
students continue to do them after
grades graduating from school this is
because they are a meaningless form of
exercise and not of any practical use no
matter how much they are taught
if people do not continue to practice
them there is very very little value in
teaching them cold-blooded cold-blooded
dig it so what should be done we need to
adopt the strong points of calisthenics
and compensate for their shortcomings of
course there are various possibilities
but for now I have come up with these
two ideas first the first is
calisthenics that incorporate training
for the defensive for the defense
against attack so the first one's like
you come up with calisthenics that
represent movements that are from
fighting right so like a classic is a
sprawl sprawl yeah go do some sprawls
you want to get in good shape me I go do
some sprawls incorporate that in one of
the workouts I used to do with my kids
when they were little is they'd have to
do five sprawls and max pull-ups every
minute on the minute for five minutes
just five minutes
see how many pull-ups they could get to
do five sprawls and use many pull-ups as
you can to see how many this is a brutal
workout go try that yeah no you don't
need to be an eight-year-old kid you can
be a 46 year old man go hit that for
five minutes yeah five sprawls max
pull-ups go but he's a good workout for
kids yeah but legit but anyway sprawls
that's an exercise where it debt
reflects exactly the movement that you
would do on the mat now here we go back
to the book my other idea could be
called dance style mm-hmm and I'm not
gonna get into he talks about he's
basically saying like hey you come up
with dance moves that are fun that work
your body and what I thought of
immediately when I when I thought when I
read that I was like thinking about all
the all the I guess is b-boys and
breakdancing the same thing be bullies
do breakdancing so it's like judo and
judoka
so b-boy is okay breakdance so like a
tenth planet guys a bunch of the tenth
planet guys came from the breakdancing
background yeah and they have the
physical attributes the flexibility the
strength from that and it turns out to
be awesome for jiu-jitsu yeah so there's
a good and you can find out with
gymnastics people too like yeah like
gymnastics here's a skill but I guess
his point is in his mind that's now fun
somehow see in my mind like it
not fun what the breakdancing like to me
doing a breakdance move compared to
doing a push-up yeah you'd rather do the
push-up well I mean there's not a huge
difference right yeah yeah yeah
breakdown is pretty fun you said you
don't want us young did you have
parachute pants yeah Ritchie Martinez
and Gio Martinez yeah yeah yeah well
they're there they're badass ters did
you guys and their b-boys yeah and that
that is what they attribute their feels
their skills developing so quickly so
quickly and when you when you think
about it and it's absolutely true
because you think of breakdancing moves
like how you can spin on your back and
do it like all this stuff like to spin
on your back you know these guys who go
inverted do all this stuff where they're
really good control over their like
spatial body yeah you know
so these breakdancing guys they come in
with level 10 love that you know and
well wrestlers obviously come in at a
high level gym to anyone that's really
good at gymnastics has that same kind of
awareness and they have some crazy
strength yeah so yeah maybe that is a
good thing for the for the judo players
to come up with some kind of a good
dance a dance
well what about capoeira cuz Kappa what
it was it was a fighting disguised as
dancing yes sir yeah you know it was it
was the African slaves in Brazil yeah
and if you notice I know it's cuz they
did it told it's not a thesis what do
you call it like anyway thing in college
but they did a thing on college in Kappa
water uncommon yeah okay and so I'm
gonna go into a whole long thing but
good if you go early capoeira was only
legs no you know why because they a lot
of the time they'd be tied up hands
behind their back so that yes so they
came up with this fighting system
distend disguise it is dancing to use
against their captors mm-hmm it's very
interesting that is interesting be boys
people have wait a couple other guys
Jeff Higgs went from jiu-jitsu to
capoeira mm-hmm
Fabio Fabio Santos our old teacher was
like Higgs you're the only person that's
ever gone from jiu-jitsu he kept
training jiu-jitsu yeah incorporated
capoeira yeah
even right community does the same thing
I think he no no I think he
now most people would find Kappa wedding
all that seems cool but then you get
choked out you're like I'm gonna learn
yeah yeah that goes man you ever see
note like a cop with like a performance
or whatever man there's this it's
gymnastics it's whatever you wanna call
it like this yeah man it's really
impressive it's always like he'll deal
dude
and I'm referring to this guy that you
said he'd put on a couple of show every
Wednesday at this club I worked at in
Hawaii and so he do these like flips and
somersaults and stuff like that and it
looks like oh he messed up that
somersault but that was part of the move
see I'm saying so he instead of sticking
the landing he doesn't stick the landing
he rolls into the next movie and also
it's this big string of just real fluid
mist it's kind of captivating I can see
how that would benefit okay noted yeah
all right back to the book there's no
need to reject traditional form of
exercise those who enjoy them subdue
them my doctrine is very simple highly
recommend what is best without rejecting
things of the past so I do not
particularly oppose Japan's conventional
methods of physical education but I
would like to devise the best form of
physical education and recommend as many
people as possible take it up thus
resulting in a form of physical
education that at the same time achieves
worthwhile goals that is cool right like
that's one of the coolest things about
jujitsu is you are getting in shape and
you are learning how to choke people out
which is a really beneficial fig and
then for all the people that say well I
want to start jiu-jitsu but I need to
get in shape first no you don't you just
need to start jiu-jitsu and you'll get
in shape along the way back to the book
the prosperity of a nation can be hoped
for only with an energized populace that
vitality and that vitality depends on
the mental and physical training of the
people the powerful nations of the world
have explored every avenue in order to
build their national strength and they
are paying particular attention to
physical education and endeavoring to
promote vitality of their citizens
through their own unique methods well
that sounds good and it was true at one
time but in America right now we're
getting pretty weak on physical
education
need to step it up step it up you ever
seen that video of the old school they
would did some experimental gym class
somewhere in California and like the
crazy ops courses like in the maybe the
40s or the 50s and they had crazy
obstacle courses they had this and like
every kid looked like a complete beast
and you're like yeah why wouldn't you do
that why wouldn't gym class at school be
an hour long of hardcore physical
putting out mm why would it not be that
way right yeah you know why cuz people I
am but that's insulting to my child
because he's not a great athlete well
your kids not gonna be a better athlete
if they don't start training art right
so like was it get in the game yeah I
agree
so what what is it though the kid the
kid like okay we're gonna do push-ups
today right and you know Johnny did a
hundred push-ups meanwhile I can only do
two so I feel bad that messes up my
self-esteem I don't want to put you on
the spot and you know what we're just
gonna not do push-ups yeah in fact you
know we're gonna do for PE weave baskets
basket weaving yeah but even isn't the
isn't the whole grading system I know
good a little different thing but isn't
the whole grading system in school like
that anyway hey Johnny over there gotta
a yeah yeah it is right now yeah but you
know there's the universities for sure
that have like well there's no grades
here yeah because we don't this is no
matter grade yeah actually the like no
actually your school becoming you know
what you don't know it makes my kids
about my kids will be like I got a I had
a 96 on the math test and I'm like what
was the class average who did you lose
to anyone and they're like no if
everyone got a 96 I don't care you know
your average
I don't know maybe you should care maybe
you should know maybe you should be
impressed with the teacher the teacher
is so good that they when they test
these kids these kids score almost
perfect on the tests on the material
that they touch thing that's one good
teacher right there yeah well I'd be
impressed to the teacher but I wouldn't
be impressed with my kid if they just
got the same as everyone else they need
to step it up what if they don't mess it
up what if they all got hundreds ok they
got a hundred okay like still not
impressed well
it's a good job but I'm not impressed
I'm impressed hundred perfect score on a
test my head it my wife my little
daughter will come home she'll be like
dad I got a 94 on the math test
it'll be like which one did you miss the
color she did a great job I'm not gonna
lie to her whatever that is a good job
all right okay we'll leave it you know
it's funny as I know you're really not
like that cuz I see you know what's
funny is I I do say that to my kids yeah
with this joking but it is hell it is
fun yeah like you're like a tower put
the one where at my house the pool
everyone's jumping in the pool doing
their dives yeah and you're like it's
like joking Jocko you can totally tell
you're like good dive but I want to see
improvement in this area and this it's
like over it is good I see what you're
doing this yeah we got have fun with it
sure back to the book intellectual trip
now he's talking about intellectual trip
intellectual training involves both the
acquisition of knowledge and the
cultivation of mental power and whereas
one cannot discuss these entirely as
entirely separate things is nevertheless
true that people with a great deal of
knowledge do not necessarily have
exceptional powers of reasoning or
judgment that's important just because
you went to some course doesn't mean
that you know doesn't mean you have good
judgment so you can have people that are
well read well educated but they don't
have any common sense that's that's what
that sounds like this thing here the
cultivation of these powers is not in
itself entail becoming knowledgeable so
in fact these two things can be looked
at separately so there's big difference
between you know having information and
having I guess we'd say wisdom was he
call it reasoning and judgment mmm I'd
call reasoning and judgment combined
together I call that wisdom and now he
talks about moral education back to the
book in one respect moral education must
be carried out from the aspect of
knowledge that is to say it is necessary
to know intellectually what is good and
what
evil there's also necessary to develop
the intelligence to distinguish right
from wrong in various complex situations
thus it is necessary to teach the
ability to determine good from bad to
discriminate what is right from what is
wrong this is something that I think
we're getting away from like hey you
know what that's actually wrong like the
whole idea you've you've here people and
I think it's I think they wrap this
around a political conversation or a
political viewpoint of there's some
people that say like no evil actually
exists mm-hm and some people just say
well no people are different and people
are raised differently and all that I'm
one of the people that like I believe
evil exists and and I think you can
teach and you have to teach people how
to tell the difference between right and
wrong
there's some things that are wrong yeah
there's some things in the world that
are wrong yeah and you shouldn't do them
strangely I was talking to Jay pretty
in-depth about that idea
mmm-hmm place to a bunch of things where
even saying okay things are right and
things are wrong that's that's like one
way of you know what the okay so these
people that that say well people are
different there's no real absolute right
or wrong the thing is they're they have
a point with that but here's the thing
they're not talking about the same thing
you're talking about like do we have a
societal standard so and see it got
super complex so obvious it's not the
time but think about this let's say a
fat person mhm they're fat everyone can
see that they're fat they know they're
fat kind of thing right and some people
would say it's wrong to indicator to
point out that that person is fat in
front of people even though the fact is
that they are okay is it right or wrong
to point that out it's rude it's rude
exactly alright so ant so is it right to
be rude you was it right or wrong so
little scenario dependent things right
person situation alright so the point is
yeah the point is there's a societal
standard yeah and usually it's
established just like beat like beating
your kids in certain societies is right
in certain societies is wrong
so sure the more extreme the the
behavior the easier it is to concern
okay that's all that I think there's a
there's a line yeah
that I think is and it can call yeah and
it goes all the way down to like almost
like a human a like understanding of
heat like basic human needs in sam
harris hill so he talks about um
suffering like suffering and well-being
that's the two things if something
promotes or advocates suffering for like
no reason way and he goes into it then
that's how you can discern good and evil
okay so but at the end of the day it
goes down to a standard like a specific
standard yeah yeah but what I'm I guess
you're saying the same thing I'm saying
yeah which is like you need to teach
people and and explain what the value
system is to two people back to the book
in another sense moral education must be
carried out from the aspect of the
emotions even if you can distinguish
right from wrong intellectually if you
are not trained emotionally to like what
is good and dislike what is evil your
ability to do good and reject evil will
be lacking
so if morals are not cultivated both
intellectually and emotionally good
results cannot be achieved this is big
stuff yeah this is heavy stuff back to
look furthermore even if you do try to
do good and reject evil if your
willpower is weak the opposite result
will often occur there for training of
the will must also be an element of
moral education a weak willpower can
result in the inability to do what you
know is right or the inability to
prevent doing what you know is wrong
loom this is the very important stuff a
weak willpower will you allow bad things
to happen you choosing the short-term
payoff over thee another good example
back to the book it is also important
not to look the over not to overlook the
element of habit even if you intend to
do good if you have not developed the
habit of doing so your best intentions
will easily be corrupted and even the
best intentions of rejecting evil can
fail if you have not developed the habit
of doing so for that reason you must
endeavor to cultivate good habits love
what is good and reject what is evil on
a daily basis you know what this
supports this supports that whole you
know when when I talk about the fact
that like if you make good decisions
like if you wake up early that goes
that's a habit and that helps you that
strengthens your ability to reject
weakness whereas if you sleep in your
lazy you hit the snooze button your
double-fist and donuts into your mouth
guess what you're gonna be weak then
I'll tell you something else
and I've been talking about this or I've
been thinking about this I've been
talking a little but I've been thinking
about this the way the way that you live
every little thing that you do like
those actions that you take on a daily
basis that's who you are
and if you don't train correctly if you
don't live correctly when the moment of
truth comes you won't be able to execute
correctly yeah the way you it's like no
it's a classic the way you train you the
wave train is that how you fight right
if you don't train hard you're not gonna
fight hard yeah if you push yourself
mentally when the time comes you'll be
able to push yourself you'll be able to
push yourself mentally if you're weak in
training you'll be weakened war that's
the way it is yeah those very well-put
sir
we're talking last night like I said and
that's what we were talking about -
that's what I brought up cuz he was
really excited about learning all these
new things about calculus and all this
stuff right cuz he's into AI are
efficient machine learning and whatnot
so I was like okay you know you're
really excited about learning this stuff
which is good by the way and we're just
I was I wasn't necessarily talking about
him but I'm it but just used him as the
example so he I was like okay so what is
what is it like you're so are you
applying this to like your work now or
your life or whatever or you just fired
up about learning
so it's like you can learn about
everything in the whole wide universe
right but if you don't put it into
action whenever it's like your habits
like what you do that meek that's who
you are you have like let's say you're
you're you I don't know well actually I
think you're saying something different
I know what you're saying what you're
saying is absolutely true too
I'm saying little I'm saying little the
little things matters what I'm saying
the way you live is the way you live is
what I'm saying yeah yeah okay yeah what
you're saying it is also important like
hey you got this what are you gonna do
with it yeah yeah that's what you're
saying and that also is important like
okay will you work for this but now what
are you gonna do with it you got this
gift what are you gonna do with this
gift you've got this talent when you can
do this town you got this education what
do you do with this education those are
all so important yeah and what I'm
saying is if you don't develop the habit
of putting things into place and being
efficient and working hard you can take
those gifts those talents in that
education you can piss it away you know
that's what I'm saying yeah if you're
used to taking the easy road you get
that knowledge you don't do anything
with it yeah so live your life with
intent that's what I'm saying every day
every little decision you make matters
it matters matters what you do
expanding this out a little bit back to
the book if each member of a group helps
others and acts selflessly the group can
be harmonious and act as one accordingly
the group can make the best use of its
energy just like an individual this
principle remains true even in the case
of a complex society with a population
of millions you help each other out this
is very this is what this is you know
this is like a SEAL team right this is
like a seal platoon you help each other
you support each other that's what makes
you good that's what makes you good
here's another one let's say someone
draws a sword on you this is getting
back into training let's say someone
draws a sword on you any hesitations in
your actions will result in you being
injured or killed
you must react automatically
instinctively
just as when you blink impulsively when
a fly approaches your eye you must dodge
your attacker an instant in order to do
this you must pratik practice this as
physical education and train on a
regular basis to build up your body
while also undergoing martial arts
training so I like this idea of a fly
getting your eye right the fly doesn't
hit your eye you blink that's what
happens you have the instinct and what's
cool I see this with extreme ownership
when people first hear about the concept
like it's foreign to them a Utah you've
talked about this how once you started
thinking about it you'd see like any
excuse that someone makes you're like oh
man this guy's not taking ownership
that's just an excuse and then you see
it in yourself and when that becomes
your instinct because you're living that
way well then it's very easy to spot
it's also easier to maintain yeah that's
why the little things matter that go yes
sir
back to the book judo began with the
study of martial arts and then it
gradually became clear that it could be
applied to physical education
intellectual training moral education
social engagement management and
people's everyday lives some people
believe that judo means simply
practicing at the dojo this is applying
the principle of Judo at the dojo
when practicing defense against attack
and though it certainly is one aspect of
judo is only a small part of it with
judo in every endeavor you must imagine
the best goal
and use your mental and physical energy
the most effective manner in order to
accomplish that goal for that reason
judo is not merely a martial art but
rather the basic principle of human
behavior it is wrong to assume judo ends
in the dojo so he's saying apply this
everywhere I'm saying you should do that
you can do it with jiu-jitsu now we're
going back into this sere do Co Zhen you
certain teachings have a long tradition
so most people accept them but when
people do not understand why they are
taught a certain way conflicts conflicts
can sometimes arrive arise to give
example virtually no one doubts that
diligence is a good thing right
no one doubts that diligence is a good
thing if diligence is always a good
thing it falls that there can be no
situation in which being diligent is bad
but if you are diligent in an
irresponsible manner you will spend a
great deal of effort on something that
is not very useful and expend the energy
required to do something good
wastefully you must carefully choose
something for which diligence is suited
even when we do what we believe to be
best over doing something can be harmful
when students stay up late reading a
book because their teachers parents or
society has deemed it best that they
should read it this is certainly
diligence but is also detrimental to
their health to read for so long
conversely you cannot do things
half-heartedly
or randomly so you got to stay balanced
let us turn to the into an annoying yet
pervasive habit o people
all too often display complaining what
is the point of complaining it is
certainly no fun for those who have to
listen to the complaints the energy used
to make an unpleasant complaints can
certainly not be considered Serio kou
Zhen yo rather all the energy used to
complain or grumble should be expended
more usefully this means ridding oneself
of unpleasant feelings and refraining
from harboring ill-will towards others
the
this end in the end this will result in
putting one's energy to the best use not
only for oneself but also for the
betterment of society this principle
should be applied everyday at all times
don't waste your energy on stuff that
doesn't matter
back to the book if people are always
aware of their current situation and set
a standard for their future based on
doing what will benefit themselves in
society and continually regulate their
behavior they can be satisfied with
their lives at all times when you try to
do this you'll find that your future
prospects are always bright that is
because you're doing what is best
how how common sense is this right and
it's so common sense but how many people
do you know that follow this path that's
the question
yeah that goes back to how you say that
idea of being detached when you detached
it's common sense yeah but when you're
in the game it's not common sense
because of how you just like how that
said how you feel like you know like
even complaining for example like you
could ask I don't say literally everyone
but you could ask everyone and be like
hey complaining is that useful is that
good to do is that fine - you know just
complain right yes or no everyone's oh
no no no no
what does everyone complain that cuz
when you're in the game complaining if
you could I feel better whenever you
picked up on it very well because it's
as if people are always aware of their
current situation meaning they need to
be detached and then set a standard for
the future based on doing things that
just think it's the same thing sleep is
it smart to do things that will benefit
themselves and society continually
continue regulate your behavior so that
you're satisfied with your life and
although of course that makes sense sure
why don't we do it we get off the path
we get on the slippery slope we start
losing our awareness of our what is it
current state well how do I put it in
the current situation for institution
yet understand it yeah this is
interesting
through judo we are teaching a principle
that can work together with the highest
principles of Buddhism and Christianity
and the exhaustive studies of
philosophers one where
like other great philosophies and
religious can be put into action this
principle of Judo offers a basic
principle that can provide a sound
answer for every situation in every
question the easiest way to master this
basic principle is to practice the Wazza
of judo and to embark on the dough the
way that is because through practice
that incorporates both a martial art and
physical education one can learn a
method for making the most effective use
of one's mental and physical energy then
one naturally learns how to apply this
method to every aspect of human affairs
I believe that this basic principle is
the most appropriate method for
resolving various moral issues then he
puts a lot of weight on the judo a lot
of weight on the judo noodle is life
yeah with regard to our daily activities
and social interaction the teaching of
Ciriaco zen yo means bringing about
maximum results through the use of every
sort of energy for this reason human
faults like anger for example violate
this principle becoming angry consumes
mental energy
how does anger benefit you or anyone
else the result of anger are invariably
a depletion of mental energy and being
looked down on or disliked by others by
following the principle of Serio guzheng
yo people will not be able to get angry
being disappointed or troubled by
failures or setbacks or harboring
grievances are also ways in which mental
energy is consumed arguments fights all
of these are violations of Serio cuisine
yo those who practice judo must take
great care to follow this teaching no
matter what the situation there is only
one path that people must follow in
every case the only course is to
consider what is the right thing to do
and proceed in that direction
what is the right thing to do and do
that you know what is the right thing to
do and do that that's what you should do
regardless of how you feel yes I have
coined a phrase that I regularly say to
people there is only one path in life
conducting yourself in accordance with
this principle on a daily basis is
vitally important though human beings
may reach the pinnacle of success there
is only one path down which to proceed
that is to say because complacency gives
rise to the cause of failure
you must always consider things
carefully until you find the appropriate
course of action and proceed that way
even when you fail there's only one path
down which to proceed even if once you
fail and lose heart
if you regain your courage and find your
way along the highest path the highest
path circumstances will gradually
improve that's like Jordan Peterson
talking right hey you know like get on
do the right thing
pick a little thing and start proving
that then clean your room because they
find their own paths
those who practice judo and who follow
the principle of serial cuisine you
always have a calm spirit enjoy life and
are enterprising the most advanced
mental life can only be achieved when
people thoroughly absorb this principle
city oku Zen u maximum efficiency what
are you doing that is taking away your
energy what are you wasting your energy
on back to the book a true a person's
true value is determined by how much he
or she contributes to society during his
or her life and because these very
contributions enable those who strive to
protect themselves to achieve this the
purpose of Judo is to perfect yourself
so that you can contribute to society
this applies to ordinary people as well
again this is very very similar to what
Jordan Peterson talks about like you you
need to if you if you fix your world
well do you impact me everyone's world
around you mm-hmm this applies to
ordinary people as well but in
particular those who specialized in judo
must be expected to act in a way
consistent with the
purposes of Judo when you practice judo
you must try to perfect yourself and
contribute to society through this
practice and you must emphasize the
importance of this during your teachings
to others something that seems good
because it is near at hand may be
useless in the future whereas in some
cases a bit of patience is highly
effective in furthering your law in the
future right delayed gratification the
basis of happiness in life is found not
in the pursuit of material gains or
temporary pleasure and true kindness
towards one's friends means giving them
serious advice when needed selflessly
without fear of offending them now that
one's interesting because I deal with
this one a lot right
I deal this with a lot because you got
your your subordinate that's not doing
what they're supposed to do and I just
was having this conversation with a
group I was working with and they were
real big on the word transparency of
life and I talked about it on the
podcast and and if here's the question
like I'm gonna be transparent with you
like like hey echo your videos you you
know they're not good right now like
your videos aren't good you need to
tighten up your videos like does that
make does that improve our relationship
does that make you want to do a good job
for me does that make you want to like
get out there and really crush it mmm no
not at all
so you know I'm being transparent
doesn't help our situation doesn't help
what we're trying to do no it doesn't so
I need to figure out a way to tell you
something and normally the best way to
do that and here's a big hint for
everyone that's out there if you want to
give someone critique that they know
that you know they need one of the best
ways to give them critique is to take
ownership of it take ownership of the
problem so I say echo hey I feel like
I'm not really giving you good guidance
on on the videos and the way they're
coming out mm-hmm I want to sit down and
talk to you and actually go through like
what what the impact that we're trying
to have
I want to have and I mean I know you're
working hard but I feel like I'm not
giving you good enough guidance I want
to sit down with you and try and see if
I can be more clear mm-hmm right does
that offend you no well I know you're
doing now but yeah yeah yeah yeah so you
take if you take ownership of the
problem and then you talk about the
problem with the person it puts it
doesn't it makes it makes them not have
a defensive posture which is what you
which is what you want you want don't
want them to have a defensive posture
mmm I actually want to have them have an
open mind and be able to listen what I
say they won't listen if you're pointing
the finger at him yeah they won't listen
as well they might listen for a little
while yeah but it won't be a lasting
they may be years later maybe or
something like yeah won't help the
relationship we know that I'm not sure
you must remember that the purpose of
expending a great deal of effort to
build a strong body is to enable you to
undertake jobs that you might otherwise
be unable to endure so what he's talking
about there he's dog mouth he basically
goes on this whole thing about like
being big and buff sure he's not pro in
that down for that's not down for the
calls like echo Charles he would look at
you and think you're wasting too much
time on your on your bicep curls yeah
might be right yeah so that's what he's
saying is that he's but he's all about
the functional strength you want to be
strong so you can do jobs that you might
not be able to endure if you didn't work
hard
didn't work out hard hey that's a
balancing act too I know you're gonna
defend the biceps I mean of the curls
but but you know how like they say it's
even like like kind of like because
about example but he said you wanna save
your energy essentially for jobs that
are like important rights no no he says
the reason that you're trying to get
strong isn't so you can look big and
buff it's so that you can do jobs you
can endure jobs that you wouldn't bail -
okay gotcha so that that should be the
focus of your training functional
strength functions what these are he's
down with the functional strength this
guy need to super funny bro science I
think I told this deep bro
it's life for someone so funny and he's
talking about functional strength he
said so you know it's jokes or whatever
anything yeah so good luck you can
compare your functional strength with my
actual strength but in his mind actual
strength so it's like how much you can
[__] and yeah you know how it is well
yeah that's so not every time I hear
like when a guy's starts like heavily
advocating functional strength over like
uh some some weightlifter guy or
whatever I think about that that's even
though I'm sure this book came out a lot
a lot you know earlier than bro science
life Jack alright back to the book some
who practiced judo become overconfident
of their health and inevitably fail to
look after themselves
we must not be careless about where we
live our clothing or our hygiene we
should pay great attention to what we
eat and drink there was a time when
people did not deem it a problem to eat
and drink to excess but rather we're
proud of a prolific a proud of being a
prolific eater or a heavy drinker that
way of thinking still persists and is
obviously detrimental to health if you
do not take care in regard to matters of
health there is no benefit in practicing
judo those who practice judo must not
only keep this in mind but must also
consider it their duty to remind others
that's bolded their their duty to remind
that was a star next to that this guy
did again this guy is like super orderly
yeah and he's you know just gonna
tighten people up you know he's out
there going don't eat that doughnut yeah
but to the nth degree
yeah that's your duty come on bro yeah
you know it's my duty I'm gonna go you
know I'm gonna go to the mall and buy
the food court you know what's funny is
this is the only thing in the whole book
that he says like Judah won't help like
if you if you're not healthy do does not
even train stop train he has a thing
yeah he doesn't like that
yeah he's what's that called a pic I
hang up yeah that's yeah that's the
thing
yeah because judo derives from the
martial arts of the past it must
perpetuate the spirit of other martial
arts
loyalty faith honour and various other
virtues were emphasized in the martial
arts of the past but I keenly feel their
importance even today the deterioration
of society's morals today is primarily
the result of a failure to emphasize
these virtues so I believe that those
who practice judo in particular must
apply themselves to these matters and
restore today's neglected public morals
he's got another little hang-up I wasn't
ready to hang up he's but I mean
obviously I'm pointing this out because
we could clearly look at society today
and be like err well guess what we were
on a slippery slope yeah yeah you can
tell you feel strongly about that all
right there who me or heal him oh yeah
yeah yeah what about me yeah just yeah
the look on your face indicated that for
sure yeah you know that's a whole nother
thing it's it's weird cuz you go around
different pockets of the world in
different pockets of the country and you
see various various positions on the
slippery slope
some people hanging on yeah but some
people are not and they're just slipping
and we gotta be careful yeah and you get
and obviously that's a whole nother
topic but the you know and you have so
many huge major major forces kind of
working against it you know pushing us
to down the slippery slope like
marketing right you know like marketing
most marketing is to appeal to your most
like immediate wants double whatever you
know it's the girl that's showing the
delicious burgers like yeah and guess
what doesn't even cost that much mmm you
know so gratification for cheap yeah man
so you can get it in the sex throne on
top of that yeah make you feel good you
know what you know and that's everything
so you know again if you're not what is
it conscious of your situation or
whatever you might know sleep
like is like I think people lose
concentration that's because most people
in my opinion most people are like they
kind of know you know we like we go back
to the theory of right and wrong what's
right I think most people are pretty
good with it like most people feel
pretty like that they know what's behave
like it oh that's wrong right and they
know that hey you know what that's a
good thing to do right I think most
people kind of like broadly kind of kind
of a would agree with those things yes
the problem is and so that's why I think
we don't emphasize as much because we
think you know what most people pretty
much agree with me like it's like the
center people of the country right now
like and the extreme right now the
extreme left no okay where are you at
it's like okay well those people that
are in the middle it's like yeah we we
kind of figure like okay pretty much and
so what happens is once we don't talk
about it as much well then the people
that are on the fringes mentally they
end up without a compass right they just
don't even know what's right and what's
wrong anymore because people aren't
talking about as much because it doesn't
seem like we need to mmm I think we
might need to yeah yeah and why it's
right then it comes down to your
approach and like all this stuff cuz you
know when you have opposing views it's
like if you don't do it with the right
approach you just it becomes more about
the fight more so than for sure you know
the kind so yeah I think you're right
about that
I think our and are you talking about
people most people know right and wrong
because there's a difference between
like just like how you were saying where
people know right and wrong but they
don't always do what's right kind of
thing probably so is that what you're
talking about like well no no I'm saying
I'm saying if you don't teach a kid like
hey when you see someone that needs help
you go help them Yeah right like little
old lady crossing the street right right
that seems obvious a little old lady
cross the street she's got a grocery bag
you you go okay hey can I help you with
that grocery bag and you know help you
put it in your car maybe for you you get
a little pump while you're at it with
that groceries yeah hope she has a bunch
yeah so like that's that seems like a
real common-sense thing to do and that's
like the most basic example I can think
of off the top of my head like okay so
that that would be a good thing to Train
a kid to do hey if you see someone that
needs some help you give them some help
yeah especially an elderly person that's
having some trouble that's what you do
yeah
seems real obvious but what I'm saying
it and and I think even I think most
people most kids would be like oh yeah
they'd see that and they would tend to
go ok I'll help out but because most
people would tend to do that we think we
don't need to teach him good and that's
where we're losing it like because the
people on the fringes they're not
helping that person there's someone on
the fringe that's gonna like oh they
drop their bag move steal it from them
yeah right so that's where we end up
with a problem yeah yeah sure and that's
why these things probably need to come
up as part of a conversation a tional or
universal conversations to be had like
okay what is right and wrong who's given
those guidance is now yeah where are
they coming from evil are people three
people aren't reading the Bible anymore
to look for their guidance they're not
following Buddhism to get their guidance
from right they're just they're just
kind of going around yeah so where's
that coming from
yeah that's true they're going like
going around they're seen like what okay
they're looking around me like okay what
are we doing how are we doing this is
right is this wrong now and you do it
and what are they looking at to get to
measure to to establish that from you
know what they're looking at Instagram
yeah uh whatever's are on the mat
whatever's around but instagrams around
me you to man around them yeah that's
what's around them and they're looking
at it going okay well this is you know
that seems so weird all right cool
that's what we're doing yeah yeah okay
to sucker-punch this you know this this
old dude yeah yeah you know I you know
and I feel a little uncomfortable on it
but you know what it seems normal
yeah people are doing it fun yeah guys
are laughing I got a lot of views got a
lot of yes maybe that's what's cool yeah
that's what we need to watch out for
yeah and obviously I know that's an
extreme case but really that that that's
true we're especially okay in these
extreme cases will happen by the way
if you don't have any other presence of
influencer you know how like kind of
saying this it thought it made sense
where kid your kids or whatever they're
gonna learn how to behave whether they
learn it from you or your neighbor or TV
or the guy at the club or the guy at the
park whatever that part is up to you
like if you don't want to be there
they're gonna learn it from somebody
else kind of thing so that idea where
okay what are we you know this is a
society like okay what are we doing now
how are we doing this what's right
what's wrong is this wrong now whatever
then we're gonna get that does it guy
you said like we're looking around we're
trying to see what up you know and if
there's no specific thing saying or
court not quote necessarily a course
yeah even though of course would be cool
if there's nothing present there to
demonstrate it then they're gonna be
like all right well what is here to
demonstrate it and what I'm saying is
we've gotten away from things that in
the past would have guided us at least
someone and you'd had this sort of sort
of fundamental Universal understanding
of like thou shalt not kill right sure
well okay that that that's a biblical
thing and well you know maybe when a kid
is 15 years old and he's feeling angry
about something and he's thinking you
know what I play a video game all day
where I shoot like people in this video
game and that makes me feel better
well maybe make me feel better to go out
and do that in a school yeah right
that's that's that's what happens yeah
so if we don't have if we don't lay out
these things for people even though most
people don't need them there's some
people that need them that's my point is
that we've gotten to a point where we
think you know what pretty much everyone
kind of gets it and if everyone kind of
gets it I don't need to emphasize that
much yeah and so I'm not gonna emphasize
it yeah well there's some people that
need it yeah and even if you don't
quote-unquote need it it's kind of like
exercising you know a great shape I
don't got exercise wool yet you kind of
do you know yeah it's interesting times
yeah this is interesting speaking of
interesting instructive talks on morals
presented in the classroom often become
abstract or involve stories of people
from the distant past so they're not
likely to inspire the listener but moral
lessons that can be acquired through
judo's randori are based on facts and
are much more likely to make an
impression
and it can be said that the habit of
observation the ability to make
decisions quickly and the ability to
remain calm and resolute that are
cultivated through fighting are also
valuable outcomes of the practice of
Judo these abilities however will not be
developed merely by doing kata and
randori training without any thought
these abilities will naturally develop
when one takes care and fought in
practicing them on a daily basis so this
is this is something very interesting
think about so I thought that was great
like hey you learned about something you
know you read the Bible you know it's
like ah that doesn't really make sense
to me it's some guy that lived thousands
of years ago and well I don't really get
that I don't really get why I should be
humble because it says you should be
humble well get on the mat now you get
humbled and you feel you get humbled
right so there's that's that's like the
perfect example of how hey what you
learn on the mat is is truly understood
but if you're don't get no and if no if
you don't think about the fact that hey
that reflects life - by the way that
reflects life by the way if no one makes
that connection for you that's
problematic and I mean clearly jiu-jitsu
this is a big difference between
jiu-jitsu and judo if we talked about
what the competitions are like you talk
about how you get disqualified
jiu-jitsu you have people and jiu-jitsu
that have bad attitudes right but they
don't they don't apply what they learn
in jiu-jitsu so one of the things that
you know you know my attitude always is
with jiu-jitsu is like if I get if I
beat someone in jiu-jitsu if you're if
you understand jiu-jitsu if you beat
someone in jiu-jitsu you realize that
doesn't make you a better person than
the person that you beat what it means
is you've trained more than them that's
what it means or it means you caught him
that time means you got lucky with a
move it means they made a mistake and
you had trained enough to be able to
capitalize on it it doesn't mean you're
a better human being than they are and
there there are people in jiu-jitsu that
think oh I am a better human being than
that person is because I him out it's
like actually no not true at all yeah so
if you're not connecting these bigger
broader lessons and connecting jiu-jitsu
life then what you have is just just
this isolated sport which diverges which
is a it's not even a sport it's an it's
an isolated might makes right attitude
on the mat which is not a good thing
yeah it's not a good thing at all
jiu-jitsu should be making you humble
because you should recognize like oh
yeah well I've been training longer than
this guy and that's why I can beat them
and one day if they keep training more
than me they'll be able to beat me so
hopefully I'll keep training and we'll
have a relationship and we'll be able to
support each other and that's the
attitude yeah so I think that's one of
the things where you know you've got in
my mind you've got judo on one side
which is you know really strict and
controlled and and less evolutionary
because it doesn't evolve as much and
you have jiu-jitsu on the other hand
which is wildly evolutionary it's
incredibly creative like there's a
there's less creativity in judo there's
way more creativity in jiu-jitsu and I
think in the middle especially on the
attitude part is where jiu-jitsu now is
like you need like you go to jiu-jitsu
competition like little kids that are
they have their bad sports right their
bad sports teams they did not learn
sportsmanship hmm and that's an
important thing because what a
sportsmanship mean sportsmanship doesn't
just mean like you're a good sport on
the mat no it means that in life you can
handle getting beaten and you're gonna
get back up and you're gonna have a good
attitude that's what sportsmanship is
that's why you're trying to teach that
to your kids Yeah right and there's a
million little things like that in
jiu-jitsu that you learned like just the
hard training well you you know what in
jiu-jitsu sometimes you work hard and
you still get beat yeah that's the way
life is yes sir that's the way life is
you work hard you give it everything you
got you still gonna get beat well guess
what do you learn from that you learn
about life from that yeah the creativity
part if you're stuck in a box on
something and and he talked about that
earlier like oh yeah when he's talking
about there's only one path again I
talked about him as being a very I won't
see not creative but he's got an orderly
brain right
I never look at something that there's
one path yeah like and by the way if I
fail in business he's like hey there's
only one path no if I fail in business
I'm actually gonna look and see like
well okay what other path could I take
now he's talking about the path like
like I'm not saying hell no the hell
with discipline and I'm gonna do
whatever I want so he's saying stay on
that path and that makes sense but there
is a certain lack of creativity there
like okay well if I make a mistake I'm
to assess and I'm gonna see what I can
do differently
again I'm not arguing that that's that
he was saying no don't ever try anything
else but that is an important piece that
you learned from jiu-jitsu like oh if I
can't pass the guard this person's guard
this particular way I need to take a
different approach you learned that from
jiu-jitsu and you can apply it to life
so all these lessons that if you don't
pay attention to what you're learning in
jiu-jitsu and you don't reflect on it
and put it back on your life well then
all you're learning is how to fight
people and beat them up well then
jiu-jitsu is not doing what it should
it's not doing what it could be doing
for you yeah look you need to be careful
that yeah I think his thing his one path
is is it's this really broad in general
kind of Dura it's more of a direction
yeah it is it is that's a bad example
for me to use but at the same time I
want to make sure people aren't like
well you know I'm gonna stay on the path
I'm gonna stay the course I'm gonna stay
the course you know what we failed that
time but it's okay I'm gonna stay the
course I'm gonna keep going no no no
assess see what you can do differently
all right effective use of mental and
physical energy again he's he's talking
about this sukira Zen yo an integral
which is integral to the teachings of
Judo competition can be applied to many
aspects of life those who practice judo
must measure their behavior by this
principle on a daily basis and make
corrections when appropriate if you
actually apply this standard to every
aspect of your life from food clothing
and shelter to your work and
relationships you'll find that you often
have to correct your own mistakes
those who do this will make progress
day-by-day in advance in life those who
fail to do so will never progress and in
many cases will regress so keep an eye
on those little things
with regard to memory in the early
stages of practices of Judo you must do
what you have been taught in order to do
this you must remember things as well as
practice progresses you must you must
remember not only what you have been
taught but also what you have observed
so there are many situations in which
memory is vital you will develop that
ability naturally to come up with ways
to remember things he's talking about
some of the benefits of learning judo so
one of those you learn to remember
things next we come to the area of
imagination this is not particularly
necessary during the early stages of the
practice of Judo but becomes quite
necessary later you may experience
experiment with various outcomes
carefully anticipating how your opponent
will react but if there is a limit to
the ideas you can come up with and if
the range is narrow no good ideas will
come to you no matter how much time
passes on the other hand if you come up
with a variety of ideas one after
another and if your thoughts extend to
things quite different from your
original idea you can come up with a
perfect solution among those ideas so he
talks about creativity and this is
interesting next come loose language
this is very important to the practice
of Judo the reason is it is the reason
is that in randori as well as in kata if
you try and explain a particular method
in words unless you explain it
exceptionally logically and clearly your
listener will not understand what you
mean there are some things that can be
demonstrated in detail using kata while
others do not lend themselves to this
method in some cases you must explain
things in writing or verbally when
teaching whether you demonstrate things
through kata only or by giving a verbal
explanation while demonstrating the kata
makes a big difference to the listener
this is a truism when you ask something
when you ask someone about something you
do not understand or discuss something
in depth it is highly beneficial if you
can talk about it clearly
thus it is so in the practice of Judo
take care take care to discuss things
logically and clearly so even he talks
about the importance of being able to
express yourself and having good command
of the language hmm
it applies to judo is that reaching
maybe
a little bit but we'll give it to him
I'm gonna give it to him do you know
yeah the way I see it is like you know
that what is the laws of combat simple
oh yeah that's that's what sighs yeah
for sure yeah you're right good call I
like it
next I would like to discuss the need
for broad-mindedness broad-mindedness
means open to new ideas as well as the
ability to organize various kinds of
ideas at the same time without mixing
them up the reason this is important to
the practice of Judo is that when there
is no broad-mindedness people often
become overly confident in their own
beliefs such that if there are new ideas
that are superior not only do they not
accept these new ideas but in doing so
they failed to determine their value and
whether they are good or bad this is
something you see all the time with
people with ego a closed mind they don't
listen anybody else they don't come up
with any new ideas it's horrible so keep
an open mind my way or the highway
yeah or is that a different thing you
don't want none of that my name is aiwei
yeah this is speaking of simple the
theory of Judo fighting includes some
quite complicated ideas when we consider
the relationship between the body and
the four limbs their positions how to
use them how to handle the mental
aspects one theory gets mixed up with
many others so it becomes difficult to
reach an overall conclusion even if we
link these complicated theories to look
at them separately the ability to unify
them in the end must be the second
requirement for broad-mindedness you
can't be able to connect things you
gotta be able to simplify things this is
interesting
there is a teaching in judo competition
that says one must look at the
relationship between oneself and others
and one's surroundings so you have to
orient is is the zoo de Loup yeah this
is a loop so you have to you have to
orient yourself to what's happening you
have to look around and see what's going
on another one in judo fighting there is
a teaching sake
ohtori which means anticipate simply put
this means using your Wazza on your
opponent before he can use his walls
on you boom be aggressive default
aggressive don't wait for the enemy to
do something mm-hmm you do it first
there is another teaching in judo
fighting do Kiril donk oh and this
translates to decisive action after
careful consideration Dookie arrow means
carefully considering the situation
before attempting to use a wasa donk Oh
means acting without delay once you have
made a decision when this teaching is
applied to the path people take in life
it can indeed be relevant in many
situations this is a good one what
youyou consider what you're gonna do but
then once you make a decision you go you
go full speed you go full speed you
always reassess you always keep your
mind open even when I'm like I made a
decision like hey or you know what we've
debated this enough let's go even when I
say that and I mean it I'm still just
making sure I always make sure yeah yeah
and then I run to my death it seems like
he's more talking about like don't don't
don't don't make a decision go and then
hesitate the whole time that's
definitely true and also don't sit there
and wait to make a decision you know
make a decision but this is what's
interesting here's here's a conch back
to the book a further teaching which
seems to be somewhat contradictory to
donk o is known as toe tomaru
kokoro o Scheider and that translates
know when to stop this means that when
you venture to use a Wazza up to a
certain point but when you reach that
point you must stop again this rule has
universal applicability to many aspects
of life as well so there you go you got
those two opposing forces one is like go
and the other ones like know when to
stop so those are let's just say very
important one of the most important
concepts and judo fighting says if you
win do not boast of your victory if you
lose do not be discouraged when it is
safe do not be careless when it is
dangerous do not fear simply continue
down the path ahead right those are
normal face yeah normal face yes
affirmative when encountering social
pressures such as those such as those we
experienced today even an incredibly
strong willed person can lose spirit and
experience great adversity this is when
we must this is when he must show true
character at times like these the
ability to overcome difficulties endure
and be patient preserved ones honor and
maintain a spirit of integrity are truly
valuable above all else in order to do
this first you must develop good daily
habits these good habits include
simplicity and moderation and while
thinking of yourself always keep other
people and society as a whole in mind as
well you must not trouble others for
your own convenience and if you can you
must try to benefit others while
benefiting yourself in other words you
must perfect yourself and contribute to
society which is the ultimate purpose of
the study of Judo then judo is a lot
bigger than you thought it was it is yes
sir he's trying to take it to the
distance no way those who want to do
something to benefit society must first
make sure they can easily take care of
their own business yeah clean your room
yeah as Jordan he says take care of your
own business you know then you can worry
about the rest of society look two
oxygen masks you put it on yourself
first then you put it on your coz if
you're suffocating how you gonna help
your kid you're not you can't here we
get a little controversy professional
wrestlers and boxers are generally
people of low character I don't know if
they can sit on oh definitely don't sign
on with that and no matter how superior
their skills they're mostly looked down
on by society
I guess we'd have to do some research as
to what the boxers and wrestlers were
like back in his time in Japan some
Kodokan members have gained popularity
popularity performing on tour with them
but I don't believe this behavior is -
is in accord with the aim of Judo true
judo practitioners must not be
performers hmm so that's there you go
right that explains a lot yeah sure he
won't like McGregor no no no I'm like
down the pond for sure
McGregor don't care no all right
and this is this is again I I had to
call these things out because obviously
I don't agree with ball wrestlers and
boxers being people of low character in
fact I believe the opposite of that but
here's a good one in the future when
asked to compete against wrestlers or
boxers the competitors must decide
whether the judo practitioners will
compete under the rules of boxing arrest
wrestling or whether the opponent will
compete under the rules of Judo however
those contests must never be
commercialized
they must be merely trials between
volunteers for the purpose of research
if for some reason showman should get
involved people get charged admission
and it becomes a spectator sport you
must recognize that this is in complete
violation of the spirit of Kodokan judo
hmm so what about Olympic judo then
that's that's a violation yeah I mean
there's a lot of things you'd call but
actually you know judo gene LeBell yeah
he fought he fought against the boxer
Milo Savage in 1963 and I think it was
Denver I forget what it was but yeah
that was like that's kind of noted as
sort of the beginning of like whatever
popular MMA right boxer versus judoka
and judo gene LeBell is a American icon
he's an icon of grappling if you don't
know judo gene LeBell is look him up
he's awesome
and he actually so he did this back in
the day back in 1963 what do you think
the outcome was boxer versus judo yeah
in a fight fight no they fought they
fought they fought like in an MMA fight
I mean it was it was an it was you fight
each other
go let's gene the bill then yeah that's
Ching the bell all day right yeah
takedown rear naked choke that's what he
got
yeah that's what he got that's how it
went so yeah that's you know it's just
interesting how completely
commercialized yeah this is and it's
also interesting that again closed
mindedness or I don't know if you call
it closed mindedness but he has a very
orderly brain yeah and he was like look
it's either gonna be those rules or
these rules he didn't think to himself
like hey you know what what if you just
mix it up and you do it all together
yeah all rules yeah all rules why
wouldn't we do that which is interesting
because in judo they do cover striking
and you don't hear about it much but
they have those are part of it hmm so
it's interesting that in his mind is
like knowing it's either those rules
yeah these rules yeah very rigid yeah
very rigid thinker yeah that's a good
point
back to the book in everyday randori
practice fighting against another person
is not the real purpose of the practice
of Judo because fighting to see who will
win is interesting it is done on a daily
basis yes it is it goes without saying
that becoming able to beat someone is
one of the ultimate goals of the
practice of randori however there's
clearly a difference between becoming
able to beat someone at a future time
and becoming obsessed at beating someone
now in order to beat someone now it is
best for those who are strong to use
that strength to overcome the other
person's strength however with that
method if you encode encounter opponent
who is much stronger than you are
you will naturally lose so even if you
lose for a while the correct practice of
randori is to slip dexterously away from
your opponent adapt to his strength
caused him to lose his balance while
stepping back and then take advantage
the opportunity to perform a Wazza if
you do this kind of training you will
for a while often be twisted by the arm
and held down or push down by your
opponent but if you do not frequently
engage in this kind of training you will
never learn how to beat a stronger
opponent so this is what we talk about
all the time when we talk about relaxing
and trying to relax and putting yourself
in bad positions and not using your
strengths that's what we're talking
about and again that applies to life as
well
that applies to not stayin in your
comfort zone not in continuing to
concentrate on what you're good at
mmm focus on your weaknesses that's what
that talks about it's interesting his
how he said don't don't be focused on
beating the other guy you know it's
almost like holier talked about that
real briefly right when I first met him
where Hughes I got like it's not like
you're not looking how big the guy is
how tough he is what belty has and all
this stuff it's like you're focusing on
on your jiu-jitsu what's lacking what I
know and don't know
you know if I'm focusing on the other
guy in ya I'm gonna beat him and all
this stuff that's not what what the
jujitsu is yeah and I'll go ahead and
say this like this is this sounds good
it's but we all I mean at least every
single person I trained with like we're
trying to we're trying to wait yeah
that being said now actually I'm gonna
go ahead and correct myself like we
train we want to win but like you take
way more risks training with our with
our training team then you would take if
you were training with someone else
yeah right you take you know you take
rescue try new things you put yourself
in a bad position so I'm gonna try this
I'm gonna try this arm lock I'm gonna
try this choke even though I might end
up on the bottom but that's okay well
you know what I mean so I guess that's
true I don't focus completely on just
trying to beat the other person yeah so
that's that's actually very accurate and
I think as you are as you start this
game that's the best attitude to have is
like hey you got to relax I was talking
to a buddy mind that's just starting
jiu-jitsu out and he's like my age and
yeah he's like man I'm trying to relax
Parker tried to relax harder and
actually what I do I send him a text I
was like it's like rock climb
have you ever done a rock climbing
before yes so there's technique in rock
climbing like there's legit technique
obviously well it's not obvious if
you've never Rock climbed before there's
a massive amount of technique in rock
climbing it's the way you position your
fingers the way position your hands the
way you use your legs you don't hang the
weight on your muscles you hang it on
your your bones and your ligaments so
you're not getting tired your muscles
aren't getting tired out because you're
using the technique if you don't know
rock climbing guess what you do you hang
on to the freakin rock with all your
muscle and just as long as you can
that's exactly what happens in jiu-jitsu
when your technique is good you're just
gonna hang on yeah you know that he the
whole thing about you Justin winning and
he and he used the word obsessed yeah in
reason when you really look at it I mean
as in the moment yeah you want to beat
the guy like that that's when you train
or someone in jiu-jitsu or especially
when you compete in jiu-jitsu that's
actually where the shift kind of curs he
mentioned competition as not a spectator
sport this is just for experimental
purposes research research search
purposes which is essentially just
training really for sure it's kind of
like kind of how when they started the
first UFC that that was what they were
kind of pushing to they're like we're
gonna see how what martial arts style
exactly right and but really you know
the people the thing that people came to
see was that for sure but it was a show
who's gonna win and oh yeah yeah and
when you really look at it so you see
one two all these things it was I don't
want to say rare but it was almost rare
when aside from points Gracie of course
and you know Ken Shamrock and stuff like
this it was really rare to see the style
get maintained it was like these karate
guys had their stance and the fight was
started as a street fight yeah exactly
right so and that was part of the
research kind of kind of thing but you
know people were there to see who's
gonna kick whose ass but it in jiu-jitsu
when you're really when you really think
about it you we are kind of maintaining
that like we want to see like we're
researching all the time yeah and useful
work and you're you can you can fall
back and forth like sometimes you can
get sucked into being obsessed with
beating that guy and maybe if you kind
of use it
you know it's like using anger to help
you I don't know get more strength or
something just for a moment or whatever
I kind of think that's okay and I think
we all kind of do it in one way or
another not the anger thing necessarily
but that I'm gonna like me in you for
example I might incorporate a little bit
up today so I'm gonna get Junko today
that's what I'm kind of focused on it
for a second yeah yeah for a second to
help me get better maybe even get me
past a mental barrier or something like
that and you know you can do it but the
big picture is just what he's talking
about I just want to get better it might
do kind of thing and I will say this too
I eagerly positive to be like yeah I
don't want to lose and and the only way
you're not gonna lose is to train all
the time yeah so the days that you the
days you're like well you know I don't
like yesterday I I was on a different
time zone came back it was I got back in
the day I had a work to do as soon as I
hit the ground I got done with that I
hit a quick workout and now it's like oh
it's guess what time it is jujitsu time
and I'm like well you know oh well you
know maybe it's been a long day look at
my shoulder kind of hurts right now so
maybe I'll just you know dress then I
was like no go go to train because
because what I know is not training no
it's it's this is not training one day
might not make a difference but that one
day does make a difference you might not
you might tell yourself it doesn't make
a difference but there's that there's
something in there is every day of
training you can get matters every day
counts you can't get it back and if you
miss it you miss it especially like
right now alright well I've been
traveling a lot lately
way more than normal so I know like if I
gotta get there I get my rounds in got
to get my rounds it that's the way it's
got to be and part of that is my ego
brothers my ego saying look I gotta just
you know I gotta fight I got a straw
gonna be stay on top we gotta stay on
top of the mountain as high as I can
like hungry minds and the young bucks
are out there they're coming after me
yes I appreciate that
mmm but that keeps me in check my ego
the positive party he goes that I do I
do want to win mhm and I don't want to
get beat
now that being said guess who I trained
with my train with all the guys that
most likely to beat me that's what I
want I want to have that happen so
there's a balance there's a good balance
there and at the end of the day there's
really no escaping and I think it's real
prevalent like for you and Dean and the
it's really prevalent we're sure you
have all that you have all those
thoughts you know in your head or
whatever but it all comes in the whole
reason you have that thought is to get
better at Julie for sure it's yeah
because I when you start jiu-jitsu you
like some people say even me
like well you know I'll just I just want
to get good enough to like you know be
able to defend myself well after six
months man you're good so what am I
doing here 25 years later still didn't
save dad because like there's a couple
guys that I will I you know I want to
keep ahead of or even with or catch you
know like that's what's driving so
there's there's a definite ego thing
involved but I think the other where
that goes too far
the ego goes too far this is an obvious
answer is like oh I don't really you
know I'm not gonna train with that guy
because he might catch me right then now
you're not now you're not progressing
now you're in this thing that he's
talking about like you're not gonna
progress because you're not gonna train
with that first or you're not gonna take
any risks whatsoever so you're just
gonna defend defend and you're like oh I
survived around and I'm out of here yeah
so you got a you you got to keep that
attitude of like hey I'm gonna get beat
yeah and you know that's the thing
jujitsu works man yeah jujitsu works if
somebody catches you yeah doesn't matter
who they are right they catch you
jujitsu works you tap out you go again
that's the beautiful thing about jujitsu
yes that's the beautiful thing about
life cuz in life you're not gonna win
every time you're gonna call it you're
gonna make mistakes
someone's gonna capitalize on them so
what are you gonna do you give up and
even more important than that you can
lose you can lose is whatever thing
you're trying to do you can lose you're
trying to start a new business you can
lose you're trying to get a new job you
can lose you can lose in life so are you
gonna prevent that from even getting you
let that prevent you from even getting
on the mat in the first place on even
trying to start a new business even
trying to try to do something that's
outside your comfort zone that's what
this that's what this is saying get
outside of your comfort zone yeah don't
sit there it's not gonna help you yeah
and you can see it with with the guys
who you can tell or just focus on like
being the guy who be
the other guy kind of thing then I'll do
those kinds of things they'll roll and
then when they after you know two three
rounds when they're they feel their
steam kind of going down the leave where
they'll sit on the side and talk you
mean like I'm not rolling anymore
we're the only real small guys did that
- Andy yesterday what we did like six
rounds and I was like Brian ease our
backup because you know he's training
for events you know I'm like I'm I'm
gonna give I was like hey I called dr.
Luke I'm like dr. Luke
give me some help over here and he's a
backup yeah yeah
yeah you know cuz gotta got to get him
to step it up but what's interesting or
what the reality is when I have the time
or when I'm not when I have the time but
like I always get my rounds in - like
we're doing if we got two guys that are
competing and we're doing you know two
and one out like I put them through and
then I go through it - because I want to
get my training because I'm trying to
get better - right to your point yeah
you're not in there I'm trying to get
better yeah and that's exactly what I
mean and it's obvious you know but you
know you know it's a big symptom of
someone who's who's focusing on the
wrong thing is like if they don't do
well or whatever and they say stuff like
oh you're lucky this is in MMA or
something like that or they're like
they're unhappy about the fact that they
got pressured by you specific like a
cetera this guy will remain nameless um
and that's what he'd always say like oh
yeah if there were strikes I would have
won kind of thing you'd say that kind of
stuff all the time I was like brah
focusing on the wrong thing right now
the fact that you quote-unquote got beat
or I beat you and this is how you
would've beat me you know you focused on
the wrong thing why do you think I do
cuz I do this I do the opposite when I
roll with someone and I'll be like hey
you know like I'll catch him or whatever
I'll back yeah you know hey if this was
MMA like let's say I'm gonna remember
fighter catching I'll be like hey you
know if this is MMA you know you're on
top for a while you didn't you'd have
been pounding me in the face I would've
been good you would want more if I'm
going against jiu-jitsu guy and I catch
him or something I'll be like yeah you
know though if that was points though
you were up like eight points you
probably beat me that was a that took me
15 minutes to get so you wouldn't want
yeah and it CIA obviously I don't know
exactly what's been on your head but it
seems like that would be something you'd
say to someone to make them kind of feel
better because you know
it's a little mini competition in there
for real I mean that's essentially what
makes it so good because he's giving you
an accurate look how in a motivated
opponent attack or whatever would look
like he's going full-speed against you
so there is that element of like we're
competing against each other and when
you lose this kind of light loss to this
guy especially if you're not that used
to training or or so I'm just being nice
you're being nice I think yes and at the
same time if you've seen stuff like hey
if he this was MMA you'd be pounding me
or something like that that there could
be a little element of your own training
kind of like you just went to lots like
yeah I kept that in mind where you know
I would have got hit there and you're
just kind of voicing it may be for the
benefit of yourself as well as the day I
don't know that that's what it seems
like what happened
it's almost thinking those things Chuck
well you know that's we could go on this
book for a long time I think that's a
good place to reflect and say look
there's a lot of principles that you can
apply judo and Jiu Jitsu there's things
that Jiu Jitsu
should you should take from Jiu Jitsu
and things that you should take from
judo principles and if you mix those two
together you still get something that's
really powerful not just on the mat but
something that's really powerful to
apply to your life again is everything
in this Theory's perfect no somebody
asked me that the other day I was with a
group of young leaders and someone
because I was talking about how it's
beneficial to read about history and
understand warfare and understand it
gives you an insight into human nature
because you insight into people the way
people think and all this stuff and this
guy says hey do you ever think that
maybe what you read was wrong
and if you apply what what was you read
you'll actually end up making a mistake
or do you just follow what you know
history and I'm like no that's the whole
reason I go because the more you read
the more you understand the more
different angles you see and I'm
questioning every decision I make I'm
questioning all these things all the
time and I'm using all these different
information that I have in my head as
sounding boards to check off of like
what well at least let me shed some
light on it
gather some intelligence that's what
that's what I'm trying to do so yeah
question yourself and question these
theories that's what I think that's one
of the best things about
it's one of the best things about MMA
and jujitsu and fighting right now is
that it's evolving so fast and and and
it's open for it and if you're not down
for that right now you're gonna be left
in the dust you're gonna be left in the
dust does this mean that every fancy new
move that comes out should be applied to
your game no it doesn't mean that at all
does it mean that every fancy GG Jitsu
move that you saw in Worlds would be
super effective in a fist fight no it
doesn't mean that at all but should you
have an open mind to understand that
some of those things could be absolutely
beneficial um yes you definitely should
so keep an open mind with everything
that you're doing you know that idea of
broad-mindedness sometimes I wish Kano
would have had a little bit more
broad-mindedness yeah cuz that would you
know it would have been beneficial you
know that's one of the sad things about
judo as they they outlawed the double
leg takedown in judo you can't do it you
can do it after you've done another
takedown attempt so it can be like a
follow-on gotcha but that's not cool no
that's not cool and it's the same thing
with with jiu-jitsu right when they
outlaw certain submissions like the the
heel hook with G Jiu Jitsu Yeah right
like the heel hook is still there the
heel hook itself is still there in the
in the the motion of yeah that area you
shouldn't a lot it should be part of it
because then you have people ending up
in positions where they're not effective
fighting positions they're not because
you can get heel hook in your gear never
torn apart yeah so why would you outlaw
something that's very effective it's
it's I understand there is some danger
in the heel hook for those of you that
don't know the danger of the heel hook
is that it doesn't create pain before it
creates industry it injury well it
doesn't create a lot of pain before it
creates industry in injury so you can
feel you can have a heel hook on you and
you can be like oh I can get out of this
and the person starts applying
pressuring you like oh that doesn't
really hurt and then pop your get your
you have to go get surgery now yeah
that's the problem with heel hooks but
if you and your training partners
understand that and if competitors
understood like hey if I get caught here
I'm gonna end up in surgery if I don't
tap yeah so that's the if you understand
that then you won't go in these
positions that where you're exposed to
heel
so that's what you should do not only
with jiu-jitsu but you should do with
life to like understand what really
works don't outlaw things don't avoid
things just because you're not good at
yeah open yourself up to him
do you know why they don't come they
really don't allow heel hooks in ghee
competition do you know why are you
asking yeah but you know the reality
that they say I think it's because the
the possibility of injury yeah the nogi
they let it lie because you can slide
more and I don't know and I think that's
I think that might be just tradition but
hopefully you know they should allow
double leg takedown Xin judo they should
allow heel hooks and jiu-jitsu in engage
it's ooh now this doesn't mean if you
roll with me and we're rolling G you
just slap a heel hook on me because I
won't be expecting that and I'll be
pissed or that should be part of
training yeah and so congratulate is oh
yeah I guess you're right I can't
tighten it up yeah let's see that is one
of those thing here's what it is with
the helix Wiggy
like if someone Busta cuz it's so widely
known as as a mouthful yeah it's a so if
you get a guys especially let's say
extreme scenario a new guy comes in he's
a purple belt hungry blue belt he comes
in he rolls with you know one of the
instructors black belt or whatever ye
you know they're rolling and he's going
super hard and he goes for a heel hook
pause right there technically the what
what as far as what we're talking about
that should be okay we're all here
training we're all getting better he's
going hard thank thanks for the good
training kind of thing he did a but
we're essentially trained to see heel
hooks with the Gil as disrespect yeah
it's against the rules you have to go
it's so embedded in it so it's embedded
in the culture really but really but as
far as what we're talking about like
it's it's really okay you know yeah look
I'll say no that's not okay
no contradictory for me because but this
is the similar thing right if you if you
came into the gym and like you went for
heel hook on me we were training key and
I started punching in the face
right that like like you weren't
expecting that but you should be
prepared for it so there is a virus if
you understand that that's what your
training like Oh are we Street rules
punches legal allowed what I'm saying
there's there's certain things that are
universally as far as I I have not been
anywhere and I talk to a lot of people I
roll a lot of different to places where
it's like you're wearing a geek you're
it's you're you're cleared hot to do
heel hooks yeah I have not seen that
anywhere me neither
it should be that way well I mean Chris
Technica thing is I'm with you and you
know there's exceptions of course and
just because I happened is it Craig
Craig Baker will allow even say yeah
yeah you can he look it doesn't come up
because just like never saying it's so
widely known and understood from the
beginning yeah you don't do heel hooks
with Iggy it's just but why is that we
don't really think about why is that and
doesn't want because those are the
recognized
sanctioned rules right just like the
recognized sanction rules say that if
we're grappling I'm not gonna start
punching you in the face
no but I know because that's punching in
the face in that grappling like if he it
punching in the face does deviate from
when you when you start learning to do -
unless it's understood that that's the
kind of training you're gonna get so
here's the thing okay when I put on the
eat these root these moves are not
allowed right
there's no yeah I don't know there's no
rules I mean sure IBJJF but you know
muscle is a probably bigger percentage
of people that do jiu-jitsu have never
competed in IBJJF tournament probably
the majority people yet we're following
IBJJF rules in training sometimes even
though actually the key competitions
I've never heard of Aggie competition
that allows he looks yeah you know but
who that's not the point the point isn't
that they're not allowed so don't do
them that's not the point the point is
why are they not allowed given what
we're just talking about there in my
opinion they're not allowed because of
the propensity or a possibility of an
injury or people think that there's a
high possibility you could get injured
they're in here they're somewhat
accurate because it is a different kind
of pain it was a lack of pain and so
there's a little bit accuracy yeah I dig
it and I see if you know specially if
that is true
as far as why they want it because some
people might sit they don't want it
because jiu-jitsu was always looked at
as this linear thing like Donna Donna
mentioned kind of mentioned part of this
where you know you get past the legs and
you work your way up his body to tap
them out and you can start tapping them
out when you get up to the upper body
and the legs were just something you had
to get past because they're gonna try to
kick you and you know they have leverage
on their own body and all this stuff and
that's it that's traditionally how we
look at jiu-jitsu and that's the
effectiveness this is the best and all
this stuff now you get you know a new
person or someone from samba or whatever
will come in and be like oh that's
jiu-jitsu or let me go ahead and kind of
flip it upside down a little bit
invasions what this jiu-jitsu and
they're like we don't like that kind of
thing yeah that could be why I'm just
saying that's what every why yeah could
be why could I ask you this I have I
have heard like that people's initial
reaction I think I've heard Dean's here
that's like if your reaction is like oh
that's not good for my game we'll just
outlawed yeah but that's what it
resulted here cuz all jiu-jitsu guys are
training this way you don't did hey do
you double leg takedown SAR not good for
judo against a wrestler you get someone
that's been wrestling for 27 years and
they come and do judo competition they
hit a double leg it's not good for the
judo player yeah they're so guess what
kind of thing yeah and so guess what out
long yeah which is a bummer right and so
yeah I'm not I'm not pro out long that
was the ultimate point there that's what
I heard of so let me ask you this do you
think in training Hugh hooks with the
gay just you personally you think they
should be allowed he looks we think he I
think they should be allowed every time
all the time everywhere but they are not
right now
and therefore in my mentality is like
okay because I'm not gonna put myself
into a position that a heel hook is
available to you unless I know that
they're not available exactly yeah I did
and I dig in and actually I agree that's
the same thing like like if we were
gonna roll and I just did it no good but
if I said hey before we rolled like one
we're walking there even right before we
kind of you know shook hands whatever I
said hey Hugh hooks are a go that would
change the game yeah we change the game
for sure
so same thing like if you're doing
noogie and you know guys like they just
don't know or whatever they'll grab your
shorts they'll grab your shirt rash
guard or whatever they'll grab it you
know because they just don't know even
if you it's the same deal less dangerous
of course but same deal where it's like
when you start doing that they'll stop
be like hey you can't do that kind of
thing but if you say before you roll
hate yeah you can grab shorts or
whatever up to you just don't pull them
off or something like that it's kind of
one of those deals yeah you could I
guess make some ad hoc rules before you
start rolling but yeah or just go with
what's universally accepted at this time
slaps in the face or legal sometimes
it's cool whatever check all right
well like I said a lot of stuff to learn
from judo and Jiu Jitsu to make yourself
better in those sports and in life so
good yeah but the I I was actually
pretty
I don't think impress but pretty yeah
impress but the whole book yeah yeah
except for the part about telling people
how to eat telling people how to eat the
calisthenics are no good yeah being buff
is a waste of time there's definitely
some and is some truth to that or this
it's weird cuz as I'm preparing the
podcast I'm like okay do I just say the
things in here that I agree with oh yeah
yeah that's one way I could do it do I
because one thing that's I I was
thinking about when I read a quote from
a book people do they kind of think like
well I agree with that
like I support this unless I outwardly
just reject it
yeah and I kind of did half the book
where I was like well you know I don't
want to talk about that because I see
where he's coming from but that's not
really my gig and then I got to other
parts I was like I have to talk about
the fact that he thinks that this stuff
is you know this is a completely
different than what I think you know
yeah so yeah I guess I try and explain
myself as I talk about it but yeah
there's there's definitely some things
that that I don't agree with there's
some things that I don't agree with
about about judo like you know there's
things that I don't agree with about
jujitsu I think that's why I think
there's a good mixture of the two that
would be very powerful
bring we need to bring Dave camera on
yeah you know some of these other guys
that have grown up in judo and are
savage at jujitsu yeah okay anyways cool
well speaking of you know getting better
in jiu-jitsu and getting better in life
sure any suggestions on how people could
get better yes so when you get when you
start doing jiu-jitsu
okay you're gonna get that's probably
one of the one two three maybe four
questions you're gonna have the first
four what kind of gear get you get
that's gonna be one of them that's my
guess that's my prediction
um sure you can be in jiu-jitsu and
still say hey gee should I get you know
whatever anyway here's the answer Origen
you get an Origin Heat
that's what you do because they are
factually factually see a rigid and
being right there's actually the best
keys they're all made in America by the
way different types of G's there they
got some new stuff by the way Pete just
sent me some new stuff it's not that new
they're just different like styles it's
not geese it's what I get some sweats
oh okay which happened to me happened to
be the most comfortable sweats in mics
you said you knew you said to me
sorry bro you know something must be
joggers but nonetheless back to the
geese yeah get them at origin man calm
that's a good one
support yourself support the Jews it's
support life support of America America
yes they're made in America you know
from the dirt to this shirt from the
dirty t-shirt the cotton that has grown
in America gets it turns into Iggy
somehow Pete does that part isn't it
kind of cool to think that when you put
on a geek like there's that Becky came
from a factory in Maine came from from a
factory in Maine that was built
specifically to make jiu-jitsu jeez and
that there's people up there
the workers up there craftsmen up there
that are sewing that ghee for you and
then it gets put from Maine into a bag
and sent to you isn't that kind of right
it is yeah
not like Kennedy Kennedy have soul I'm
gonna ask you that question
Kenickie have soul we don't know the
answer that yes yeah but we can make it
an assessment from the outside and if
Agee has soul then you'd want that soul
become from Maine right and if certain
Keys had souls and some G's didn't have
souls you would for sure want the gear
with the soul yes
understanding and if keys do indeed have
souls which I tend to believe they do
they could then you'd want the good
souls the American soul for me yep
well if Pete starts making shoes you'll
know that they'll have souls Wow echo
made of funny MLS or domain.com that's
where you get them also in jiu-jitsu
okay we gotta be honest here in
jiu-jitsu
its physical you twist your arms your
neck your body not twist like injure it
but you know it gets some work yeah and
with work needs recovery with recovery
comes supplementation good
supplementation krill oil I feel like I
said the word krill oil probably more
than I've said any other food item or
dietary supplement in my whole life good
I'm tired too happy about it because of
how the benefices got it got more krill
oil too by the way from Pete with the
joggers which are nice by the way also
another one called joint where for these
are all Jaco supplements by the way if
you didn't know super krill that's just
regular super chocolate super girl joint
warfare which is another formula for
joint maintenance reconstruction someone
said hey I got knee surgery is this
gonna help me yes yes it will help your
knee recover especially the meniscus
situation Julie yeah
oh yeah okay anything we're okay so
money I'm not gonna go too deep into it
but anything involving cartilage like
these squid that don't get a bunch of
blood flow oh yes they tend to
degenerate over
well everything degenerates but over
time ik not for everyone
ya know complacency right no back you
know nonetheless joint warfare that's a
good one
maintain the joints and this goes for
any kind of physical activity your
joints will thank you or you'll thank
your joints you'll think Jocko for jock
will krill oil and joint warfare also
discipline not just regular discipline
is a supplement discipline it's a pre
mission cognitive enhancing because
people were making stuff that helped you
physically like a pre-workout and then
they were making nootropics that would
help you mentally like your cognition
sure and well in my job especially my
old job guess what I needed both yeah I
needed to be mentally sharp and I needed
to be physically sharp yeah so I wanted
everything in the same like mix sure
blend that's why we made the discipline
yeah and you didn't want to do the
pre-workout and then boom and then okay
let me go in the other one right here
okay the home and then you know you want
to get them both get them both one time
one hit one win and you feel it and it
feels good yeah that's what like
yesterday is talking about the rounds I
did yeah cuz I knew I was coming down as
I was gonna pay the man saw sure hit the
discipline yeah tastes good too by the
way
yeah yeah tastes amazingly good what's
interesting about it is that spunk fruit
yeah it's monk fruit you know about monk
fruit no monk fruit is the sweetener
that's used in discipline it's like
whatever eighty seven thousand times
sweeter than sugar but it's just as a
root but a little bit so you only need a
little tiny bit in there low glycemic
and next slow omelet lacing the glycemic
it doesn't give you the insulin spike
and we'll just say and that's good oh
yeah and just so people know there's
caffeine in it
but there's only 15 milligrams of
caffeine so you're not gonna get jittery
but you get a little a little micro dose
yeah I've gets a little help a little
little health weather but monk food also
it like helps in eight it's it's legit
yeah it's called discipline tastes good
because jock wants it to taste
good yeah that kind of freaked you out
he had through mail for sure he thought
maybe I just want things to taste
horrible so that's more discipline not
black you I like that I was like
interesting that that was part of the
focus but hey good I say good well
you're gonna be really happy that I have
this attitude when the when the protein
comes out sure in chocolate yeah the
mint chocolate chip
you know just FYI mm-hmm it's not normal
and it's got the monk fruit in it so
that's the sweetener so it tastes delish
and it doesn't taste like anything else
there's no way that it could taste this
good and and be what it is Scott yeah
yeah I just made up I had to make up my
own name for it yeah yeah dig it you did
the right thing it's called Molk mo LK
with the oom lot over the oh you know
why tripping to Motorhead mayor's good
man I think that's good so yeah pretty
soon people gonna be on the mold when is
that a couple weeks we've got it we went
through the final testing it's so uh
it's so it tastes good it's easy to
digest easy all the good things yeah cuz
and they so remember back in especially
it smoke yeah
the kind of something you need this is
like I don't even know what to say
this isn't it's not like a chocolate
milkshake it's not like a protein shake
it's like but it's like mega mass I
think was five thousand or three
thousand was it five thousand probably
no I was one thousand two thousand five
hundred it might have been okay I think
that was at South Park those five
thousand right double super colostrum
seven nonetheless it was super delicious
it was like a big like dog food bag full
of mega mass what five hundred or
whatever it was chocolate you drink it
and it tastes straight up like a
chocolate milkshake and guess what it
probably was just a G I was gonna say
that's the thing that's yeah these are
all kind of like quote health foods
nowadays I call this approach you look
at the look at the thing on a protein
bar yeah
and compare the protein bar to a
Snickers bar yeah it's like the same
content inside of it uh yeah whatever
yes be careful I saw a hell it's cool
that's what was cool about discovering
the monk fruit is being able to make
stuff tastes really good without having
the crap
artificial sweeteners in it yeah in a
way that's kind of going back to your
roots right that's where where it's like
okay we got sweetness sweetness is a
thing it's a natural thing we'd like it
you know for a reason all this stuff
cool man don't do away with the
sweetness yeah but you know when you
start engineering foods to like to do
kind of like the advertising I was
talking about the wait maybe I should
come up with something that just tastes
horrible you just have to gut check to
taste it just to test yourself mentally
yeah yeah see how good that oh yeah
gotcha nonetheless that's gonna be
available the Molk is gonna be available
in a few weeks
apparently yeah from the joint where fur
and super krill and this is a good idea
by the way do the subscription their
recurring we're eight kids so you don't
got to remember get down to your last
three pills cuz you don't know if you
have like six pills that's two days in
my case I don't know how many you take
but I mean I know how many you take but
I don't know how many other people do
you get six pills in there
you don't know how many pills in there
you go one pill okay I know there's only
one at that time too late even six pills
technically it's almost too late pretty
much you go subscription don't worry
about that stuff
boom get the subscription also like we
said geese rash guards compression gear
joggers most comfortable ones in the
world in my experience I don't know
maybe there's a more comfortable one
maybe not if there is I have never seen
it do the job just have a soul probably
felt like it they touched your soul be
comforted it for over a hundred percent
hundred percent or gin main calm good
way to support also in Maine the Jiu
Jitsu immersion camp you immerse
yourself in jiu-jitsu for half a week
great half a week and a half a week
there's like two sessions can you do
both sessions yes you can I mean is that
like a thing of course oh yeah okay so
there's an option for that boom one week
immersion into jujitsu
just learning you know it's not like
boot camp were like you know you're
gonna be forced to do a bunch of
calisthenics which we don't advocate
apparently anymore
kono still we still advocate counseling
I had the key Kells especially like a
burpee situation which i think is I
advocate all kinds of cows all
calisthenics actually you can't show me
a calisthenic that I don't advocate even
though people like are like suit ups are
no good they work your psoas mostly
don't even know I advocate them too I
like strong sauce muscles yeah yeah good
yeah just tell me they were like oh that
doesn't even work your abs it works your
still has muscles like cool I've strong
psoas muscles next question for Soph yes
they do work your abs trading trade
don't do sit-ups for one year yeah well
your other stuff and then do five sets
of burnout sit-ups and then see if your
abs are so in the next day don't see
that mean to failure hug that's a
burnout can you even do sit-out sit-ups
to failure oh yeah it's hard and it's
gonna burn how much time you gotta have
you have the whole day here's the throw
the point isn't how many sit-ups you can
do or don't can't do the point is that
people saying sit-ups don't do your ab
muscles you know they do that too but
they do you have muscles nonetheless I
agree with you do you do jumping jacks
yeah I do jumping jacks to actually do
jumping jacks last week you're part of a
metcon but still there was an old old
team guy workout jumping jacks pull-ups
I'm sorry jumping jacks push-ups you
just do jumping jacks and push-ups and
you think it's no big deal and then like
you're 45 minutes into it like I hate
jumping jacks and push-ups yeah I don't
know if I'd ever do something
continuously for 45 minutes
yeah well that leave it at your first
half of that workout yeah I don't get
especially have to do anything to get
any exercise and you can make it suck
after 45 minutes yeah like there's I
came to think of an exercise it doesn't
suck after 45 but you know he's doing
buds neck rotations just do that in the
teams - yeah you're laying down I was
like you're like okay I'm just gonna lay
down and move my head around Oh laying
down yeah I never you lay down neck
rotations one two yeah ya do that for 45
hours you're like this is the dumbest
thing I've ever done
life but glad we're doing it yeah yeah I
think you're right about that sure the
met well I figured that key would be if
you don't like the whole 45 minutes
thing is you do something that's hard
enough of a movement that you don't have
to do 45 minutes yeah that's that's good
if you don't want to just do something
like socks before five minutes
I did a metcon like just kind of
representative of what you were talking
about earlier where it was it was like
how many of this these two movements you
can do within a certain amount of time
yeah so I said which was different
usually I set my rest time to a certain
time and I do them in full and yeah
that's a good good little changeup yeah
do that or you can do the jumping jacks
and pull-ups push-ups swoosh I mean you
wouldn't even have pull-up bars so we're
like Amish straightening the ship or
something yeah okay jumping jacks
push-ups yeah nonetheless back to origin
jujitsu camp you won't be doing jumping
jacks push-ups 100% unless you want to
you then you can you know but it's more
learning Jiu Jitsu practicing Jiu Jitsu
no pressure
unless you put some pressure on yourself
which I recommend yeah do that by the
way and roll with everybody you know do
some what's the word what's the rolling
randori randori will be doing some
randori yeah good let it good in straw
be there oh you'll be there I will be
there Dave Burke is gonna be deeper
big-time
he's got the bug yeah yeah I haven't
talked to JP and or Lafe see if they're
gonna roll up and roll oh but the camp
yeah yeah make sense yeah nonetheless it
is August 26 through September 2nd of
this year also speaking of boring
workouts
jakka workouts doing 45 minutes the
jumping jacks and push-ups I don't think
so but if you want to interesting where
actually I shouldn't I shouldn't give
you give you crap about it because I did
look on your Instagram and you had like
some Bulgarian bag yeah on there so you
got a you vary your workout your workout
gets interesting
okay I think it credit so if you want to
make your work out interesting get some
new movements new equipment and they're
gonna audit dot-com / Jaco / junco go in
there get you some good kettle bells
even though kettle bells I guess
ultimately could be viewed as boring you
can make them boring yeah yeah that's
kind of your boring yeah you know what
ultimately that's really what it is
because even me doing the same metcon
that I do all the time all I did was
switch up like one teeny tiny thing so
it's more about me than the workout or
it was work up about the equipment less
about the equipment more about me
nonetheless if you want to make it about
the equipment Anna has the equipment
maces steel bells see I haven't even
done that that's like some advanced
creativity stuff you know battle ropes
all this stuff that'll get you
functional strength and actual strength
just joking bonus you know anyway on it
calm / chuckle good spot
not a good info on there as well also
when you get this book called mind over
muscle I'm gonna list it up can you get
it on Amazon yep okay I'm gonna listen
on the website talk about lessons I've
talked down to me from the ancient book
before that wasn't available old-school
style looks nonetheless not this one
when you get it don't worry go to
occupatus calm I'll put it in the book
section with all the books
boom click through there good way to
support and you get the book boom also
if you do another shopping good continue
doing that get to leaf blower it's about
to be actually gonna be summer before
fall huh so so maybe get a weed whacker
weed whacker some sunscreen some surf
shorts yeah yeah get all that stuff good
way to support and support yourself also
subscribe to the podcast if you haven't
already itunes stitcher
google play whatever your preferred
podcast listening device slash
application is subscribe good way to
support also if you want to leave your
review
don't hesitate on that one do
Kano says make a decision about leaving
review make a decision and just go
don't hesitate on the review just do it
leave it like everything in life you
know reviews no different also on
YouTube subscribe to our YouTube channel
if you want if you care even a little
bit about the video version of this
podcast and what chocolate looks like
and I don't care if you care about what
I look like but again and I still get
this by the way I guess apparently I
don't look how I sound
easier like can you match up a voice to
a face you kinda can't huh yeah you can
yeah like you for sure but it's not like
a one-to-one it's kind of like a like
you hear the voice and then there's this
ambiguous kind of group of faces that
might go with it you know it's one of
those deals it's not just one face comes
to mind and that's kind of it's not that
but it's like I guess my face falls way
outside of the group of faces that
practically may not practically but that
that's probably probably match my voice
I guess that's that's what I hear too
apparently I still hear it so if you
care subscribe to the YouTube channel I
guess technically you wouldn't have to
subscribe to you just look at it but if
you want to support at the same time if
you want subscribe to the podcast on
YouTube also you have excerpts on there
so that's another reason by the way you
know you want to share these shorter
excerpts with people and watch them well
YouTube is the place to do it also some
enhanced excerpts that's what I'm
calling them today enhance put some
music on there make you feel good about
it here's the thing you advocate
discipline like the way you feel doesn't
matter I'll say this it matters less
then discipline it still doesn't matter
yeah when you're fired up and go do work
on that whatever when you're fired up to
go do a workout versus the day when you
really don't want to do a work guys it
then all the time people like oh I
didn't want to work out today but I did
anyways and I set a PR in my whatever
yeah why does that happen that happens
sometimes you know no get up
no I wasn't I wasn't that it wasn't that
theory if you feel like work you know
and you're fired up to go work out
that's gonna be a good workout chances
are not all the time I get it
if you really don't feel like working on
your dragging ass dragging you got 5.5
hours of sleep and you're not chocolate
by the way and you're you ate some
Snickers or something like this and
you're like dang I still got to work out
you really don't feel like it and you
have a bunch of other stuff to do and
you go work out ever talk about
snickerdoodle know what I mean I know
what us little is this guy and the
team's whose name happened to be Nick
Scherr and we were like new guys and we
went on a compass course the only food
that he brought out in the field was was
Snickers like you know like the 12-pack
of Snickers sure yeah as soon brought he
bought like three 12 packs of stickers
and though that's all he brought for
five days it didn't go down well no yeah
Owen thinks he got a mega diarrhea case
so the whole market on his nickname was
snickerdoodle after that oh yeah
snickerdoodle stay pretty funny yeah
and was already bummed out actually
after that one it's good
we had a guy named Snickers on our
football team nuh Snickers he was like
to use the center or that was his last
name know his nickname full on but I did
that's how you know how certain guys
have their nickname is so strong you
don't really you know like you yeah it
was like that nonetheless back to the
point if you're fired up to go work out
chances are you can have a better
workout same thing with the chocolates
message if you're fired up to listen to
it it might sink in better might you put
some good music on it boom might see
getting better it might not enough
enhance so it's enhanced you know
special messages nonetheless the point
there is subscribe to youtube channel if
you want good way to support also choco
is the store it's called chocolate or
chocolate or dot-com patches are in
that's been heating me up I haven't seen
beanies on there yeah you know process
well here's the thing I got a boom right
in time for July so we got that going
for us
I'm just a job hey man you know better
late than never I guess those in the
meantime apply when it's summertime and
you get to be
it does not apply maybe I'll get the
thin ones that straight lady do it for
nothing better about it no doubt about
it
Hey look you're right and we're still
gonna work hard on the beanies and get
them get them out quality can't rush
great greatness quality dude do you know
what a nine months for that's not about
Russia's quality like mega quality those
things could have been knitted from
cashmere yeah all right well I'm gonna
continue to work and you know when
they're out they're gonna be out they're
gonna be fantastic
they better be all right there you go
amazing in the meantime maybe it takes a
lot to get a a soul into a baby yep yeah
it could be in the meantime do some cool
shirts on there I think they're cool
does one equals four you don't get after
it that's a good one simple to the point
back to the book next year that's a new
one put other titles yeah all of them on
the back well all the book titles up
until the point yeah so what's nothing
to what podcast freaking you should
figure that out that's like a layer yeah
yeah the first hundred but you probably
didn't do that
I think we're Nona knows I conjured
something layers been missed that's fine
because then we could've put it on
another back of the book at 200 yeah
like the updated list layer yeah yeah
maybe maybe not or maybe I'll add a
layer cuz layers are animal edible maybe
you can add layers you see what I'm
saying um anyway some shirts on there
some rash guards on there some patches
there like I said some women's stuff on
their hoodies also decals you know what
decal is Jesse's decals Jesse's decals
here's the thing with decals where
they're they're essentially a sticker
right and we all know it because I and I
understand but he uses like this stuff
like the material for this decal is like
supposed to survive the apocalypse
like that kind decals okay
good way to support Jessie didn't play
around no not at all and this guy is
like Hughes like we you know we go back
and forth and he's like yeah I make
decals like yeah that's a good idea
whatever and then another company called
I think it was called Ashland front
something like this they got some decals
and I was like dang these decals and
obviously prompted me to okay we need
our decals they were legit they are
legit and they're on jockle store calm
vinyl a good way to support if you want
something get something also
psychological warfare if you don't know
what that is this one is it's an album
with tracks of Jocko helping you through
this is what the track is it's a it's
not a music track
it's Jocko on there every track helping
you get through your moment of weakness
and we have them I have Jocko has them
mmm even though he you know is reluctant
to admit that from time to time and what
it does is let's say you're gonna skip
the workout
I think skipping workout this is my
opinion skip and work out and cheat not
cheating on a dike you cheat on a diet
technically yes yeah it's like you're
cheating anyway yeah you betrayed your
yourself you know cuz you have a future
self seemed saying like your self of
right now we'll make like a protocol
right and then your future self
essentially cheats on your yeah yeah I
saw some meme of Homer Simpson saying
like all this guy's futures not looking
good
so yeah technically it is if you're
cheating on your past self on the diet
don't worry about that you start feeling
that feeling coming come along you got a
track for that you just listen to it and
it's essentially like chocolate telling
you why you shouldn't slip why shouldn't
slip down that slippery slope and
whatever activity some good ones on
there procrastination all that stuff
yeah check that one out good way to
support very effective to that's on
iTunes Apple music no I am those on
Amazon music Google Play Apple iTunes
wherever you can get mp3s that's where
you can get it also you can get from
Amazon you can get jakka white tea
it tastes really good it does have 15
grams of caffeine so that's a little
micro dose that's why I put 15 grams of
caffeine inside the discipline because
that was the dose that I like it has but
but it's only 15 milligrams so you don't
get jittery it also has a high level of
antioxidants that's what the pomegranate
does that's why it's a pomegranate white
tea and of course in addition to those
things it is the only white tea that
comes the guaranteed eight thousand
pound been left elite so that's good you
got that going for you even Jordan
Peterson now you know I got a text from
him and he's up to 8,000 so because he
was plateaued at 7,000 pounds as he
admitted on PI he isn't like to admit
his weaknesses either but there was yeah
it's hard
7,000 pounds pretty pretty sad Brooks no
now he's 8,000 so good for him oh good
yeah all took us a little chuckle whitey
also we got some books I got some books
I got a I got a book called weigh the
warrior kid the principles of being a
warrior and really of being a good human
being and they're in there and they are
simple and they're clear enough for it
six-year-old a seven-year-old an
eight-year-old an 80 year old to
understand them and it gets better
because this story continues in the book
way the war your kid to marks mission
and this book starts to hit on some
other principles in life keeping your
emotions under control
working hard being frugal saving money
and also dealing with Nathan James
Nathan James new bully psychological
bully a little bit different mark wants
to fight him Mark figures have been
training jiu-jitsu I'm gonna fight this
guy but instead uncle G Uncle Jake says
no you can fight him first you have to
gather intelligence on him you have to
figure out what's going on with Nathan
James understand why he's your enemy and
see if there's another way to solve this
problem beef besides fighting turns out
to be very good also mark has the
jujitsu tournament coming up and guess
what he doesn't want to compete in it he
doesn't want to do his first Jiu Jitsu
tournament why because he's
he's afraid of losing he's afraid of
failing fear of failure that's bad so
he's got all these problems how did he
overcome them well luckily uncle Jake's
in the house uncle Jake is out for the
summertime gives them a hand order that
book is going to be available April 24th
same thing with all the other books well
the last two books that have come out
it's gonna sell out the publisher
doesn't understand how many books to
make they want to hedge their bets so
they're just gonna make a certain amount
so the more people order now first of
all you'll get it when it comes out and
second of all they'll know that they
need to make more and order it from
wherever order it from Amazon order it
from Barnes Noble but go into your local
book store this is a mission go to your
local book store and tell me you want
the book
Mark's mission way the warrior kid to
tell them you want that that will help
spread the word and also while you're
helping out war your kids check out
Irish Oaks ranch calm we can get soap
you've made by young Aiden who's only 12
years old he's got his own business and
the soap isn't just any soap it's good
so then he actually called the Jocko
soap and the jock was so pomato that I
made up anything gets no credit for this
the motto is stay clean and someone said
there's a layer in that steak lean lean
that's clean so layers no big deal
yeah also don't forget about the
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
this is the manual for getting after it
thoughts and actions that will keep you
off the slippery slope and to keep you
on the path the path of discipline and
thereby as the title says the path of
freedom if you want the audio version of
that it's not on audible it's an album
with tracks discipline equals freedom
Field Manual on iTunes Amazon music
Google Play that's where you can get it
and also extreme ownership combat
leadership
broken down into pragmatic strategies
and tactics that you can apply to your
business in life boom
still on the Amazon bestseller list
still on wall street journal' keeping it
real and if you want or you need to take
it to the next level Ashlin front is my
leadership and management consulting
company
the overwhelming factor in the success
of any business or team is leadership
that's what it is and at Ashkelon front
we come to your company and train and
align your leadership so that you work
effectively together as a team to
dominate your battlefield it's me it's
my brother lave babban JP Danelle Dave
Burke you can email info and echelon
front comm or visit the website ashland
front comm and of course the muster is
our leadership seminar or only doing two
this year Washington DC May 17th and
18th in San Francisco October 17 18th
the DC musters 2/3 sold-out right now
two-thirds sold-out and it's gonna sell
out soon the SF muster is in October and
it's already a third sold-out so both of
them are absolutely going to sell out we
can't expand the spaces anymore we've
packed as as many chairs is there in
there as we can and desk so you we can't
fit any more people so if you want to
come get registered now at extreme
ownership calm the entire Ashland front
team will be there all of us including
echo Charles and by the way there's no
green room we won't be backstage getting
our getting our scalps massaged no we
will be out front kicking it with you
interacting answering questions talking
eating working out hanging out just
basically getting after it with you so
come and get it at the monster at the
monster get registered as quick as you
can and until we do the muster if you
have questions or comments or answers or
you just want to cruise with us kind of
hard then you can find us on the
interwebs on Twitter on Instagram and on
defy easy
HECO is that echo Charles and I am at
Jocko willing and thanks to you all for
listening to the podcast especially
those of you in uniform who took an oath
to protect this country and you stand by
that oath literally around the world on
the front lines and to the police and
law enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and all the first responders
that are always on call to help us when
the chips are down and then are ready to
make that sacrifice
like so many did on September 11th thank
you for what you do and let's remember
and give thanks to the people every day
like Jeremy Glick who stood up along
with the other members of flight 93 they
stood up and fought when the time called
for it then let us all be prepared to do
the same to stand up and fight if we
need to to be prepared to face evil by
staying on the path by knowing what your
principles are and sticking to them be
vigilant pay attention pay attention to
the little things the little decisions
the decisions that pull you off the path
and onto that slippery slope with bad
habits that will let you down at the
moment of truth watch out for those
little decisions instead stay on the
path the path of discipline the path
that leads to security and strength and
of course to freedom and that's the path
of getting after it
so until next time this is echo and
Jocko